Down
the Joe Rogan experience.
I got that book in the mail. You got
it. I got that book. The real man.
Have you been getting better?
I've been working on my real man skills,
Tommy bonds. This is Tom's
Segura, Ladies and Gentlemen,
Aka Tommy bonds from your mom's house
podcast and many other things. But uh,
he introduced me to a great man,
a man who wrote a book that every
man should read. What is his name?
He and Julian Ray. You, you nailed
it. And he wrote a book called, uh,
the real man, which might be the worst
book that anybody ever wrote. You know,
it's, it's epic on a lot of
levels. Do you know what I,
what I was thinking about after you left,
what it is that like every dude,
it really is his,
it's his game for getting laid was
making that he's the guy that goes like
ignore these guys that are there.
They're whistling at you and saying
things about the way I respect you.
But you know what I mean?
Like it's that play to get laid and
writing that book is just his play to get
pussy is what I'm saying. Right. It's his
plate to separate himself from the pack.
He's showing you his wisdom. Exactly. And
showing it and being like, I'm not a pig.
Right. Like these other guys. Everyone
else. I'm a different, we're over at,
what is that connected to try Castro.
So we're at Tommy's house.
You see those yellow tabs if you don't
see this live, what he has is this thing.
Um,
there's this book where he has these
yellow tabs at virtually everything
interesting in the book.
So they're overflowing with yellow tabs.
It Tommy just goes to them
and just laughing as he's
going to each tab just like
that. Every time you paint
your face, you're so happy.
I,
I started doing that cause I saw Oprah
do it with books when she had guests,
she was like, let me read you a passage
from your book. And so I was like,
I got to start marking my favorite
passages from this with posted notes.
That's a very clever way of doing it.
There are three separate chapters in this
book that address just smelling good.
He has a chapter called smell.
He has a chapter called body odor
and a chapter called sanitation.
It's so ridiculous. It's crazy.
It's all basically don't smell bad.
That is so funny. Yeah. And that gave
me that book in person, you know? Yeah.
He ran up to you in Hong Kong,
right? Yup. It's hilarious.
And then we found his dating
profile, uh, online. Did you,
did you get that too? No. Wow.
Yeah. He has a dating profile.
You don't need to mock this Joe more
than we ever, it's already having,
it feels cruel and I read it in full
on my podcast is dating profile.
He's been my plenty. He's probably like
every time he hears about it, he's like,
that one fucking book.
Yup.
If I just didn't go up to him.
Yeah.
Gave that one guy in book one asshole.
Yeah. He says he dabbles in standup too.
Very good.
I bet he's hilarious.
He should be on the Ding Dong show. Yeah,
no, they didn't crush it there. Yeah,
he would crush the Ding Dong show. There's
a lot of weird dudes out there, man.
There is. And you know I, that's the thing
is I actually was like, you know, he,
I really think that every
dude's personality to a
degree is developed as their
play to get laid. You know what I mean?
Like everyone takes their, they're angled.
Some are more genuine than others,
but he,
I think he really got into this cause he
thought this will be the way that I do
it. You know, this is, this is my
way to get girls by writing a book,
telling everybody how to be. I think
so. I think I think it, and in his,
in his mind it'll show these
other ladies that like I'm,
I'm so respectful of women that
you should give me a chance.
That's how I see it. So respectful
that I'm published. Yeah.
Is there a miss like misspellings
in this book and everything?
Cause I'm looking at all the
reviews, reviews, which are
all your fans? I can tell.
Yeah. It looks like he spelled birth
wrong or is, what's the breath thing?
Well does,
is there an e at the end?
It's part UTA breathe should be delicious.
Refreshing bad burrito. Yeah. I mean
there's, there's nine word chapters, so,
oh, there's not paragraphs. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Poor guy. Well, you know what
man, maybe he enjoys it. Everybody's
got different frequency maybe to handle.
He's like, I don't know what the
fuck these guys are talking about it.
I nailed it. Yeah. I go over
that book with a fine tooth comb.
I don't find any flaws.
Matter of fact,
I think it might be the greatest
piece of literature ever created.
Yeah. And then people started,
uh, I think you said it,
and then I got a bunch of emails,
people being like,
we have to make this in New York Times.
I bought it immediately. Amazon one
click to wells on your show. You know,
he's been getting emails,
like notifying him of either
reviews or sales where he's like,
this shit is finally taken off
waiting for this to take off.
And he just picked up this week.
It was like I've told you that story
about Joey Diaz hiding behind the curtains
of the comedy store where this woman
was on stage as what I'm used to.
She used to bomb every week.
She was open miker but she was one of
those open micros that was like always
there.
She was always there.
She was there on a Friday
night and Saturday night
and like I think they kicked
her out of the store. I don't think
he's allowed to go to the store anymore.
She was crazy. Anyway, she's on
stage and doing her usual jokes,
but Joey Diaz at snuck behind the stage
and it was back behind the curtain.
He drops his pants and every
time she says a Punchline,
he opens the curtains
and people see his belly.
His ball bag is tick and then he
closes the curtains and it's like,
it was the ultimate
like punch line machine.
Larry's and she crushed
dude. She crushed. She was,
she was strutting on stage with
confidence. She was all of a sudden people
get it. Yeah, they finally get me.
It's so great that she, and then she
did. She find out right away or no,
she never found that to this day.
I don't say her name when I talk about
it because I don't want people to know.
Maybe I said it once,
but most of the time I don't say her name
and you know though, but when she tells
people about stamps, she was like,
should have been there man. June
7th, 2003 while I was there.
The next time she got on stage or one
of the next time she got so she got on
stage and she's like, God, this audience,
all of a sudden it was like the
audience is fault. That's so funny.
There's such a funny thing
about like some of the,
I remember like some open Miker is there
unwavering dedication to sticking to
and like I'm saying,
not like somebody who's developing like
who was horrific and they're just like,
nope, every fucking time. How long you
been doing it? 19 years and you're like,
Jesus Christ. Well, you
know what it becomes man. It
becomes like their culture.
Like that's their hangout. Yeah,
that's true. They're there.
That is like amateur bowling night.
Like should you only bold if you're
going to be a professional bowler. Right.
You know,
I mean to someone who's like a serious
bowler and they watch some fuck heads
like you and I go to there,
you guys got her ball it and you
guys are taken up lanes, man.
Rolling in as hard as
you can. Yeah, totally
terrible bowling. But I'm going
to shop, put this shit down there.
Think about it man. We don't respect
that at all out of comedians. Right?
Like if you're a terrible bowler
and you go to the bowling alley,
the other bowl was like,
we have this fucking loser.
But if you're a terrible comedian,
a lot of people will look down
upon you with great judgement.
Disgust. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It happens.
I don't think that happens with bowlers.
I think so this gutter ball rolling bitch.
I think, I think it's probably like,
you know, some Canadian comedians
would ignore somebody really bad.
They're just be like, yeah,
that sometimes you can't,
you got to ignore him because then
they'll just corner you turn the corner,
you know,
and they'll ask you what the secret is.
Like you gotta tell him where
the Leprechaun lives. Yeah.
How often do you get asked
where the secret is? I got
it. I bet it's quite a bit,
right? Not really. No,
no. The secret, no, no,
like not even like a like emails,
dude, I'm starting out. Yeah,
get those occasionally.
But my email is not very obvious.
And um, the other thing is
that even if I do get those,
like if, I don't know, he was
like, I can't tell you anything,
so what am I going to do?
There's very few things you could tell
someone who's like just starting out or
someone who's not doing well or very
few things you can tell them. Well,
I usually not knowing them.
I used to say a lot more now I've got it
down to like a sentence. I mean, I'm, I'm,
I'm honest with it. I'm just like,
ride a lot, get on stage a lot. Like,
what else am I going to write a lot?
Get on stage a lot. Not only not,
there's some people that even if they
write a lot and get onstage a lot,
for whatever reason, they're never going
to, they're never going to figure it out,
no matter it is. Whether it's being a
musician or being good at fucking bowling.
There's people that I played
pool with backline play pool.
I played pool for years and these people
that never got any better than they
were the first time I met him. That is
crazy. I mean, and I know it's not a,
I'm not thinking about just those people,
but that is kind of a fascinating
thing where like they never get better.
No progression. There's a lot of
people like that in martial arts.
There's like people like that. Yeah. Yeah.
There's a lot of people
that they would hit,
they would hit this like really low
level of proficiency where they certainly
got better than the first day.
They weren't,
they weren't like they weren't the first
day but the only way to until like a
certain level and then they just stopped.
They stopped picking on. Ah, it's,
I don't think it's an
athletic talent thing.
I think it's like a focus thing or a
desire thing or that's something you
realize as you get older is that some
people do not have the ability to hone in
and, and, and like zone focus
on something really hard.
Some people have an unbelievable,
like the best athletes have this
amazing ability to focus on their goal,
on their training and what they're doing.
And then, you know, artists who like,
they focus on their music on the writing
and I, I've noticed that the eye,
there's just people, friends in life
who they can't focus on anything.
Like they can't make their job,
uh, that, that they might like,
or not like a big part of like, they're
wanting to get, they want to get,
they want to progress, but they don't
know how to focus on getting better at it.
They're like, I wish I was
further along, but you're there.
They're just so scrambled.
Yeah. At the time,
that's a really common thing
with comedians and they
pretend that they're not
scrambled. Right. They're always want to
tell you how organized they are now. Yeah,
no, no. Yeah man, I got notes
now and everything book,
they do the same God damned material
every God damn week for years on end.
I got a guy in fucking guest spot
at a club and I shouldn't have.
And like, you know, I was
like give it like get get.
I was working in the club and I had
worked with him before and this lady was
like, Oh shit. Well she goes, uh, so
he's, he's good. And I'm like, yeah, yeah,
the watch him.
And so he does that.
He does this set on the first show was
like a Saturday night as a guest spot and
he, it doesn't go well
and he was like, fuck,
you know what I'm going to do is on the
second, cause there's a second show.
He was like, I'll do a whole other set.
And I was like, all right. And I go,
well just watch it on the second show.
He's going to do a complete different set.
Cause he, you know, he was like,
ah, that was just material.
Do all this other material like,
okay.
And he just went up there and did the
exact same set as the first show and I was
like,
you like you spend 10 minutes explaining
to me how you were going to do all
different material? He was like,
yeah, I dunno. I Dunno what happened.
He panicked, he panicked,
he backed it. Didn't,
didn't feel comfortable
enough to to do it. Well,
sometimes when you're doing standup,
especially when you're new,
there's this mindset where you're so
worried about the response that you're
almost it.
Or you're telling the joke,
which distracts from your focus of the
joke, which makes the joke back and you,
you get into super nervous and then
you'd go into this weird shell and that's
when guys start busting out like really
familiar material just to try to get
back on track or to get on
track. That's true. Yeah.
So that's probably what he did. Yeah.
Yeah. You're right. And then he couldn't,
I think he probably,
he probably started with one joke from
the first side and then when that didn't
like make him feel comfortable, he goes,
I'll just keep doing the first set.
He never felt comfortable enough to
switch it up. We know what guests,
that's the problem with
those things are to,
a lot of them are by dudes
who don't work that much.
So when they go up it's a big deal.
So then they fucking panic because it's
a sold out room like on a Friday night
or something like that or yeah, I
stopped giving those out a long time ago.
That's too many disasters.
I saw some God damn disastrous.
Yeah. Friends, you know,
you let them up like yeah,
I'm starting to do standup again. Really?
How long have you been doing it? Wow.
Went up last week. Went well, you know
like, all right, go ahead. I hate I,
I'll tell you this, this something that
totally changed and it's because of like,
like just practice at anything. Changes
how you do you know, how you do anything.
And you know,
when I first started out,
all my sets were seven minutes and then
10 minutes and 15 minutes and you know,
and so on.
And there was a point where like I
could do like just crazy good solid 10
minutes sets.
And then now for the last couple of years,
the majority of the time I'm on stage,
it's like an hour. Like that's what I,
you know, you go up there and you do
an hour. Now when I do a 10 minute set,
I'm like, like what the fuck am I going
to do in 10 minutes? You panic. Yeah.
Kind of like, I really like start to like
figure like what? And then you're like,
what should I take out
of the hour to do here?
Or how do I introduce a new 10 minutes?
It's a whole different thing for me now.
That's why it's really hard for people
to do TV shows like Letterman or
something like that. You're doing
five minutes. I've done it twice.
I've done not Letterman, but I'd done
Conan and I've done the late, late show.
And uh, absolutely. It's like,
and then, and both of them,
there's a guy behind the camera
who's circling hits me like,
will you wrap this shit up? You're at
five minutes and eight seconds. Like,
that's long, you know, so he's like this
and you're just like ignore, ignore,
ignore, ignore, ignore that. Yeah.
It's distracting. It's fuck yeah,
he's just trying to get that, you know,
do his job. But yeah, a lot of those,
just trying to do my job.
People that are no Yang.
When Ari was filming his special,
there was some fucking dude
that was working the camera.
He was talking like this,
like in the back of the comedy store,
which is about as he's shooting
10 foot deep, you know,
how big is the fucking comic store?
It's a small place and this guy,
that camera's are moving back and forth,
they decided to have cameras on dollies.
Like they way over produced it.
You need to just set some cameras
up in the corners, set him up,
get a static shot. You don't have to keep
moving around the room like this stop.
But they did it anyway.
Right. So they did it.
And this guy was like directing
things. So he's in the back. Yeah.
Lenny zoom in left zoom in. Laugh.
I mean, and I'm not kidding.
There's a lot of people
were like what the fuck?
Like we are turn around and I had to
talk to people. I go, what is this?
Why is this guy so loud? And they
were like, he's been doing it.
We tried to tell him to talk like
the people that worked the door,
we tried to tell him to tone it down
but he didn't want to tone it down.
Cause you've got to talk to these people
that have the cameras, right? Yeah.
Cause they have to hear him clearly over
the laughter. So he's talking like this.
It's so distracting.
And that's the guy until you can,
I can already tell that like the,
you know,
the more people that would tell
them to quiet down, he's like,
you want to do my job?
Yeah, you want to do this.
I don't know if it was like that at
all. I didn't, I didn't talk to him.
But you tell anywhere to zoom in and then
they don't need to move on dollies and
shit like everybody wants to over
fucking produce these things,
but actually the central bank put a
camera side Bang, Buck Cameron aside.
Bank don't usually use the cameras on
the side unless there's something weird
going on. Sure. Focus on that camera
to seeing the need for a special,
it's like a wide, immediate, I want a
tight shot. It's really all you need.
They want to add all kinds
of crafty shit to it.
Like they didn't even let the comedy
store would be the comedy store when I got
there. There's all these crazy lights on
the side of the stage and it was just,
it was weird. They like changed the
lighting. I was like, you, you guys,
doctors end up, this is not this. Why not?
If you're going to be at the comedy store,
don't you think he should
look like the comedy store?
That was the point of
being there. Yeah. Why?
Why is the comedy store with these
fucking landing lights next to it?
Why is the room read? I do like
the trend. I think it's, you know,
it's become a trend now to have
to go back to clubs for specials.
I like it a lot. I love doing mine in
a club. It was my favorite special,
that's the best club dude
that closes the best club.
There's like four the best clubs, but
that's one of them. That's one of them.
Helium in Portland's, one of the
best clubs. Helium in Philly.
That's one of the best clubs. Like re
acme in Minneapolis. I never did that.
You never did acme? No
one's there. Ridiculous.
I went there once when arch arch
barker was performing. Really? Yeah.
You'll lose your mind. It's looked
amazing. It's just like those clubs,
just like comedy works downtown. Uh, go
bananas. Cincinnati. That's a good one.
What else? What are the good ones?
Are there, um, let me think. Oh,
danger fields in New York City. You
ever do that and never did that? Ooh,
that's a good one.
It's dark.
That's an evil club or some fucking
satanic shit going on. That really, yeah.
You know,
I mean it might just be literally,
it might just be like when something
like stays around too long. Yeah, sure.
I just,
he just soaks up weird vibes.
Like the comedy store definitely
has weird vibes in it.
There's a weird vibe to that place.
And danger fields has a weird vibe too.
Although danger fields for the longest
time didn't have like the best comedians.
It how like, I dunno how it is now,
but when I was there it was like,
there was some real good ones.
There was the occasional good one,
but there was a lot of
like really bad comics.
There were literally didn't work
anywhere else in the city. Yeah. Yeah.
It's on the east side somewhere. I
don't remember where it is, but I did,
I did that place a lot. And that's another
one. They like, they filmed, uh, the uh,
Rodney Dangerfield comedy special there,
his HBO comedy special where they can
feel that danger fields. Yeah. Wow. Yeah.
They filmed it with
Kennison and I think dice,
I think Dyson Kennison we're on the
same amount when they shot that.
I didn't know that. I've seen
that one. Yeah, it was. It
was Dyson Kennison and no,
no dice was with Bill Hicks,
right? Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
Pretty sure dice was with Bill Hicks.
Kinison was on a different one,
but either way they filmed the Kinison
one there at danger fields and it's just
perfect.
It's just a small stage in a small room
and everybody's shoved in there tight
and it's all dark and mysterious hand
jobs going on throughout the room.
It's a dark place, you know? It's just
weird. It's a weird place, man. There's,
there's that. There's a, there's
a few. There's a few like,
let me think of some other ones that
are really good comedy magic club.
Pretty God damn good. It's a
great, it's a great club with,
and the Ice House is the best room of all
time. Ice House. It's stupid number one.
That's number one.
That Morgan main room and people like
a more even more people in La Comics.
I'm saying,
you know,
everyone complains about how far like
it's not that you should be going there
all the time, they're wheezing. It's
20 minutes away. You wouldn't bitch.
Is the best. It's the best setup
in the country and the staff,
they're the nicest people on earth.
It's the coolest. Yeah, they're so nice.
Everyone is just all hugs and laughs
and they're all sexually harassing each
other. It's hilarious. They are hilarious.
Should be girls are mocking the
dude's penis is like openly.
I came out of it do the green room
and they were like mocking each other.
I was like,
this is hilarious.
But they were laughing and we when
people like work at comedy clubs too,
a lot of times they have like
the whole like PR thing or a HR.
Human resources never
really comes into play.
Never was used to hearing
about people gagging on Cox,
you know like over and over
again. How can we show, yeah,
so he works during the
weekend it was fucking,
you were watching like five
fisting jokes and everything. Yeah.
What do you get a complaint
and so everybody's always
there. They're more like,
what's the word you would use
loose with their dialogue.
I can imagine the a staff person like at
a club like that and then they go over
to Applebee's and people are probably
like, Yo, what is up with you?
And all your cum joke.
They're trying to serve the fucking
Jack Daniels taking strength.
Fucking told him down. Some of my favorite
people work in comedy clubs. Yeah,
they're great man.
It's a special breed.
That's another thing that we need to
realize as comedians if very important
thing that I try to tell as
many young guys as possible.
Everybody always wants to think that
there's some sort of an adversarial
relationship between
you and the comedy club.
Especially in the beginning guys like,
oh,
they're not paying me enough money
or they don't give me good weekends,
are they this and that and that and this.
There's always going to be
person to person conflicts.
But here's what's important. If comedy
clubs weren't around, we'd be fucked.
So we need people to run comedy clubs.
Yeah.
And guess who's not going to run comedy
clubs? Yeah. Yeah, us. Right. Okay.
We need those fucking videos.
They're very important and they're not us.
They're different.
So imagine being a non comedian,
working with a bunch fucking nutty
comedians all the time with other crazy
problems and their addictions and their
excuses and showing up late or Eva's
and shooting heroin on stage, you know,
or whatever the fuck they do. Well, my
shoes, that craziness you hit every year.
We've all seen people's riders.
You know where they have a fresh pair
of shoes backstage far I've seen writers
were big dudes.
Had a fresh pair of sneakers.
You imagine if you had
to deal with this shit,
I got to give this guy fucking sneakers.
He's gonna have his size 11 Jordan's in
the box right there waiting before he
goes on stage. He slips them on right
before he goes up. That's his ritual.
Green m and M's. You fuck
only Green Asians, you know
they're always doing stuff.
I was going to say Pakistani. I guess
that's Asia. That is Asia. That's true.
I did a race at club where they had, um,
they had a play station and when I got,
I was like, that's the shit.
Thanks dude. And they're like,
we got it for fucking asshole.
Who made us buy ones.
So he would do his shows. So enjoy, let
it go out and buy a fucking playstation.
Yeah. See Man, if you were a
regular person, just trying
to run a little business,
I maybe there'll be a fun business.
I'm in the restaurant bar business.
Maybe I'd like to run a
comedy club. Be Fun. Right.
And then Joey Diaz is calling
you from Vegas. Listen dog,
you've got a wide is money you got
watch this money. We got no show. Cox,
Joey and his crazy days.
I mean anybody. I mean,
think of the comedy nightmare stories
that we've heard about comedians doing
stupid shit to a club or two club
owner. Dude. I remember. Yeah, I know.
I was like, I did. I remember I did a
club years ago. I get to the condom,
like how's The condo looking?
And they're like, well the uh,
the guy that just left, he
shaved his pubes in the, in
the sink. And I'm like, dude,
I wish you would not have told
me that. And then, you know,
so and so left a piece
of salmon under the bed.
So the whole place would smell like fish.
Oh Brendan Walsh.
People do shit like that,
man.
And here's the other thing they do
when people get out of the clubs,
there's a thing that they do
when they like go to theaters,
they almost like despise clubs. Then I
remember to go back and work the club.
I worked at a theater. They have this
like weird image thing. Yeah. What's that?
Why would you be ashamed to
clubs? That's all ego could. Yeah.
And the whole thing is
like for 90% maybe more.
If you do make the leap
from clubs at theaters,
you're still going to go
back to like your drought.
Almost everyone's draw dips again.
Well Louie CK has one coming out that he
did at the comedy store and that's one
of the things that he talked about. He's
like, you know, cause he does arenas now.
I mean there's like Madison Square
Garden, he's like 14,000 people. Right.
So he does that. He does theaters. Yeah.
Anywhere between like a
thousand and you know, whatever.
And then he also does the clubs, which
is everything we would consider. Like,
I think a clubs like below five,
everything below 500 like even
like that place in Phoenix.
That's kind of like a comedy club
slash. Theater, which is a great room.
That's my favorite. I think
that's my favorite big room.
Big Room in the country.
I liked that one a, it's pretty God
damn good. San Jose. That's not even,
you can't even be considered
a comedy club candidate.
It's an old theater. It doesn't have
quite, it's over four but so you know,
you could technically
be like it was a club,
but it doesn't have the layout of a club.
It looks like actually like a beautiful
historic theater theater. Yeah. Yeah.
That place is amazing. That's a
beautiful thing. I just did West Palm.
I did it one night there last week
and this giant, giant 700 people.
John deets, halfway through.
So that pathway through,
if you're too far away and
just look at a TV like a UFC,
and I did Irvine last month. I
did a night. They're a giant ones.
I'm doing that in June.
I'm doing a weekend there in June.
So it places enormous man at that is
probably the best run comedy club.
Like they that's got Daniel's face. Yeah.
They know problems. Know their shit.
They know what else too. There's
like a lot of comedy fans out there,
but they've cultivated that
over years and years. Yeah.
And it's hard for them to get it
at a town. Getting into town sucks.
A Fat Dick if you live in Irvine. Yeah.
Irvine, it's fucking far like that.
Might as well be San Diego.
You might as well be.
The difference between getting to Irvine
and San Diego is just leaving the house
a little earlier.
If you,
if you leave the house at
three and try to get to Irvine,
it's like leaving the house at two
and trying to get to San Diego.
It is there the same time.
Yeah. I mean you really will.
It's hours. Oh my God. Yeah.
Yeah. If you, but if you miss that
traffic, it's crazy. If you miss it,
you just like, I'm here an hour and a half
early. Yeah. What the fuck? That's crazy.
You can't miss it.
But I don't know what that time is.
There's like a 11 o'clock to one
o'clock window of opportunity.
When I was emceeing I would,
uh, and I had an Irvine weekend.
I would leave at like fucking one in
the afternoon and I just really, yeah,
just hang out and do some work,
you know,
get your notebook out over some jokes and
better than freaking out in traffic at
five 45 stopped dead going.
How long is this going to last?
What if this is another hours?
It's fucking a show.
I only missed my set one time in my
whole entire career and it was emceeing
Ontario years ago when it rained,
so it rained. So you know,
everything gets backed up a little bit.
Like traffic gets worse and
I left La Hollywood at like,
it was like a eight o'clock show and
I left at like six to go to Ontario.
I got when I, when I ran in the feature
was like, all right, thanks everybody.
I was like, Shit, I missed
my set completely. Whoa.
Just, you know. But yeah,
I mean this town teaches you to
leave way earlier than you should.
It'd be like in 10 years when there's
even more people. Yeah, they're going to,
they're going to keep going unless
there's some sort of a natural disaster.
Ellie is going to continue to grow
unless there is a one of them,
the rock earthquakes like this movie
he's got coming out. Oh yeah, San Andres.
Right.
It would take some shit like that and
then everybody's just going to overrun
Colorado. Then everybody's just going to
move to Colorado. People have like um,
you know these, they proposed that like
nothing would be better for, for earth,
like a, a significant wipe
out of a certain percentage
of the population. Right.
Like for everything.
I mean that's very short
sighted on Earth's point.
Yeah. Cause I would say earth,
listen, we're the only ones out of
all the shit that you got growing,
the only ones it might be able to figure
out how to dive or to fucking asteroid.
So watch your mouth bitch.
Yeah.
Cause you want to talk to you want us
out there fucking and making computers.
Yeah.
We throw some shit in the ocean.
We'll figure that out in a couple
of generations. But what we,
what we're doing is we're paying attention
to factors. Rocks above you. Yeah. Yeah.
Bitch,
bitch earth.
You weren't fucking whining bit human
beings worried about a natural disaster.
Be The best thing to happen
to Earth. Yeah. How, how,
how much of a natural disaster?
Fuck Ed, because you got hit by,
you forgot about this. You got
hit by a planet once. Yeah.
These are just got hit by a Goddamn
planet at one point in time.
How long ago before your time? Like a
hundred years ago. It's like 18, 90,
72 before slavery was abolished.
Okay.
The guy was trying to wipe out
slavery with Earth, with another,
with another planet.
Planet came, I think, um,
I think it was like a billion years
into Earth's life cycle as a back
imagine though,
if you saw a planet in the sky and was
slowly coming towards us and it's trying
to Merce like, ah, we've
got a rogue planet.
There's a rogue planet headed our way.
Yeah.
And we have two years to do
with this. Oh, by the way,
we lied about going to the moon.
We've never actually really landed
anywhere other than earth. Sorry.
And then as the planet gets close to
people, like where's it going to hit?
The key players like changing like where
they think it's going to hit and then
it lands them in. They're like, it's going
to be North Korea. I was like, all right,
it's going to hit so hard that even
if you do leave now on a spaceship,
the aftershocks impact will below
your spaceship apart in space.
So it's pointless to leave
just every day. Maria, chaos,
machetes, billion fire. I'll all
still be gone though. Dance parties,
they would still be in their rockets
like, fuck it. I'm going to do it anyways.
We try. I think so. Yeah.
I think we could reinforce the
outside and beat the shockwaves.
I've done my own
calculations, Roger. Absolute.
Maybe one guy just thinks it'd be
cute to get that guy up in space.
Paul Allen would be up there. You
think so? Why? Watching from above?
You guys are fucked. I can see it.
Come on a be that guy though, man.
You don't want to be alone in space with
$1 billion. No, that sounds so fucking,
that's so depressing to think about.
I would way rather die. Yeah. Way.
Rob with the rest of us. Fuck yeah. Yeah.
I don't want to live in space and
some tiny community that, you know,
it was trying to suck water out of rocks
on Mars. No, no, that sounds so stupid.
Like this.
W you know how long people have worked to,
to turn earth into what
you can enjoy right now.
This has been a long process to get the
2015 and you're just kinda just gonna
bypass all that and shoot yourself off
in space like an asshole. Somebody would,
you know, they would. Somebody would,
you would have to be,
we would have to be like thousands of
years more advanced than we are now to a
point where we could like change
the atmosphere of a planet.
Like we could land on Mars and
do something like what does that,
there's a term scientific term for when
they reintroduce oxygen to an atmosphere
of a planet. I forget what
it is, but they've, they,
they've developed machines that
they, uh, could theoretically, oh,
photo genesis. No, that's, I know,
I'm just ask them how they think it's
just of you, you're good looking,
but whatever that uh, that,
that term is, um, they're,
they eventually want to do that to like
Mars. They eventually want to fly there,
set up these gigantic gas
making machines and you know,
somehow or another makeup oxygen. It is
cool. Like, you know, that, you know,
we can't even wrap our heads around
how amazing it will be. Like, uh,
the, how, you know, in thousands of years,
like we can't wrap our heads
around what life is going to be,
but we do have the benefit of looking
back and seeing like how much better our
lives are then every generation before
I'm talking about just quality of life.
Oh yeah. Like how hard life used to
be two, it's just, it's so, you know,
and you'd look at lifespans,
you know,
when people live in to their thirties
was an average lifespan a long time.
But you know what I mean?
Like you got married and you had
your kid at 13 and that was standard.
And then everybody got a cold and
you're like, well, he's dead. He died.
It was cold. That's what happens. You
get cold and you're getting your diet.
It was horrific.
And not only that,
like what we're talking about
was a hundred years ago. Yeah.
That's what's really been
at us, dude. You know what?
I always think about air conditioning,
like how fucking normal that is to us.
How you're like,
it's a hundred out and you walk in, you're
like, everything's fine now. Like it's,
it feels tangible and you watch TV and
your underwear picking your balls and
your like. Meanwhile, you could not
bad at all food on your driveway,
literally cook food in your driveway.
And then of course the reality of
there's some people who don't have that
obviously still who are like, you're
like Jesus. Imagine right now,
if I didn't have that,
like how in the worst hot day,
how horrific the quality of life becomes
like SIGNiX like Phoenix in the summer.
It's brutal. Vegas, Phoenix, Vegas in
the summer. It's insane. It's insane.
Yeah. It's hard to imagine that
anybody can endure those temperatures.
Remember doing gigs in Vegas July,
August, where like you're at,
you're at one casino, you know,
whatever, the Bellagio and you're like,
I'm going to walk to the next one.
Just the next one.
What did you forget?
You forget how the size,
the magnet of just the buildings.
Yeah. And that, that next one is,
I don't know, a quarter mile or
something. Maybe a little more than that.
That that's how far the night.
That's not far to go,
but when it's one 24
outside and you're just,
you're walking down and you get there,
you're like, I'm a check into this hotel.
Like I'm not even go back to my old
hotel cause it is a fucking Rudel adds
insane.
Yes.
I got hair dryer blowing in your face
all day and there's homeless people.
They're like, they live in
that. Do you think you adapt?
I think you do adapt to a certain
degree because human beings,
we're just so resilient and you just,
you do adapt to things.
But I think there's also people
you're like, you know, they die.
And why know that Eskimos or you're
supposed to call him Inuits. They,
their hands have adapted
to deal with the cold.
Like they don't get numb hands
like we would if we went up there.
Really there's circulations different,
their skin's different.
And I also know that like my friend Steve
Rinella was just in Bolivia and he has
a podcast,
the meat eater podcast.
He's talking about this trip to
Bolivia was pretty fascinating.
One of the things that
we're talking about us,
how it was really hot down
there and really everything.
Everybody was sweaty except the natives,
the native Toumani who or I think
that's how you say the name.
They didn't sweat like to them it wasn't,
it wasn't a hot that's under there
were used to it like everybody else's
drenched with sweat and these guys
are like barely drinking water.
You drink a little sip of water every
now and then, but you look at them,
they're not, they're not glistening
with sweat like everybody else.
It's amazing how quick the adapt
and the change happens too.
I remember like for the
first 1314 years of my life,
I lived in cities that had cold winters,
Cincinnati,
Milwaukee,
Minneapolis,
and we moved from Milwaukee to
Florida in November and in November,
sometimes in Florida it'll get all the
way down into the 50s like in south
Florida,
right?
So I go to school the first few days and
kids have sweat shirts and jackets on
and I'm in a tee shirt and shorts.
We've just moved from Milwaukee where
it's like three that day. Right?
So people look to me and they're like,
are you out of your fucking mind?
Like what are you doing? Why? Why
are you doing this? And I'm like,
this is the best day I've had in a
month. Like this is, this is really warm.
And then, you know, but
the thing is the next year,
the next year you change,
you adapt to the new temperature.
And then I was cold in fifth, then
I'm wearing jackets. Yeah, it changes.
It changes really fast.
I walked into Starbucks the other day
and these ladies were complaining about
the rain.
It's been raining so much lately.
Yeah. I'm like, you fucking crows. Yes.
Had Dumb crows were horrible drought.
They just make it noise.
And I'm like, why the why
now life giving water. Yes.
Nice in the sky. Ah, what is
it going to do with water?
The crops? Yeah. Phoebe animals.
Yeah. We don't need it. You're right.
It was hilarious. Let's shut it down.
Just people will find something to
complain about. But it's just so,
it's adorable when you see it.
This is like, this is,
ah, this is so cliche.
Like people are complaining
at a good thing.
I know it's been happening
quite often. Like, Eh,
I wish I wasn't making so
much money like at all.
It's got all these accounts
with sweat off his sex,
feeling good and get my dick.
That's a real great complained to have.
People are weird,
man. They're weird. They'll
complain about everything.
I think people just look
to complain about shit.
So a lot of times they
don't have to look inward.
There's a lot of complaining and going
on. I was just like, that's externally,
you know, venting your internal
frustrations. That's most,
I think that's most of the time. Sometimes
I catch myself doing it and that's it.
Like it's funny. It's sometimes
it's funny to problem. Yeah,
like sometimes like when Diaz complains
about Shit, Diaz complains it will be,
hopefully would complain about dressing
different flavors of dressing and just
start laughing. He, he, he's mocked
me for like everything I've ever done.
Tell me something.
What do you wish you got your fucking
fanny pack over there captain?
There was always be something,
you know,
I remember when Eddie Bravo had
this fucking wrist bracelet on.
It was like one of those
leather bracelets, you know
those rock and roll type,
the snap and a Joey walks up
was what are you waiting for?
A fucking Falcon Atlanta and your arm
Falcon.
He gave me shit just for talking to
people and because we were traveling
together and like it was like the third
person that had come up and been like,
Hey, are you guys doing shows like
they, and he pulled me, he goes,
well you stop fucking talking to
people. What did I do? He's like,
I'm trying to get in the fucking car,
get to the hotel. I want to take a nap,
play with my balls, stop fucking talking
to people. I'm like, all right, all right.
Sorry. But he was so fired up that
I was like, hey man, I'm like that.
I responded to somebody who wanted to the,
it's hilarious.
He gets in those moods if he doesn't eat,
it's ridiculous.
Especially right when
we land at the airport,
him and he has to get to his
hotel as soon as possible.
Like Joe would just be punching in like
an an address in the GPS. He's like,
just drive cars, you know,
it's just, he gets mad.
He got mad at me for what I
ate too. Like, um, because,
because I didn't eat enough,
like I just happen to like that time
and we landed and it'd be healthy. Yeah.
I ate a salad. He was like, what
the fuck are you fucking salad day?
He had like four plates dressing.
You gotta have a dressing
you fucking half a Mamo.
He's a fantastic, yeah,
he's quite a character man.
Getting mad at you for what you eat.
Yeah.
So funny getting mad at
you for what you wear.
But that's different. It's like humorous.
That's humorous. No, just whining.
It's just, yeah, sometimes. I mean
sometimes I complain and I'm like,
and you realize it's funny.
Sometimes in the middle of
complaining I'll just be like, oh,
I'm just complaining.
I'm complaining as a distraction.
I don't want to focus on something to
do with me. It's just, it's, it's weary,
weary, some. It's tiresome
when someone does it.
It's like if someone's really
negative and not in that funny way,
but in like just the genuine, like
everything sucks. Everyone, you know,
everyone's out to get me that shit.
You can't be around.
It's not healthy to be around.
There's a lot of people like that.
They get stuck in that Rut. I had an
ex girlfriend like that. Oh my God.
It was brutal. It does. It's
like a disease. She would
complain about everything.
I mean everything from food to
the restaurant to the people sitting next
to the table to this, to that, to that.
This is just like a skirt. I can't be
around there now. So just negativity.
Whereas you could be around the
same person, the same situation,
and they just notice all the cool
shit about things and you know,
have a different balance perspective.
Give a little energy to the conversation.
Be Be someone that's,
you know,
sensitive to how other
people are perceiving you
and what kind of vibe you're
giving off. Have you ever been
around the extreme opposite though,
where it's like a,
usually a girl that's just super positive
net can never see any negativity.
That shit's almost as an
annoying little delusional.
Delusional is not good.
Right, right. Delusional is
not good. There's delusional,
there's a lot. None of the things
about girls, about people. It's all,
it's like positive perspectives. Nice.
But yeah, not seeing the negative like,
well,
you know,
I think what he's doing now is
just trying to establish himself.
I know he's a crook. No, he's stealing
people's cars. Like, no, he's a con man.
Well, it's not as easy for him
probably as it was for you.
So maybe we should give him
the benefit of the doubt.
There's also a certain level of just
being naive. Really naive is better word.
Yeah. Clueless. Naive, delusional.
The girl, the guy I know that does,
that carries around crystals in our purse.
Do you,
when you smell, but truly on a girl, do
you immediately go, oh Christ human being,
period. Let, what's not hang out.
It doesn't about that bad.
It was exotic. It was exotic.
It wouldn't smell that bad.
The real problem with Patrulla
is the people who were Patrulla.
That's the real problem.
That's true. Because you know,
like there's smells you'll
associate with certain things.
Like there was a smell of citrus and they,
they,
they got these mice and what they did
was they zap these mice, his feet,
um,
and every time they'd zap their feet,
they would spray the
citrus smell in the air.
And so these mice would associate
the citrus smell with getting zapped.
So I think when you smell,
but truly that shit just,
you just think of knowing hippie.
Here we go. Yeah, that's true.
Here we first thought, here we
go. And knowing lazy person. Yeah,
you're just gonna go, you smelling,
you're like, you're a bad person.
I don't like you. It's all share.
We knew basically like sheer crops.
And how about the poetry and you can give
me some food. It's not so great smell.
Let's be honest. It smells. I
don't really like it. Honestly.
I couldn't even picture it right now.
It smells like black licorice
mixed with dirty feet.
If it was a really pretty girl,
I probably wouldn't bother you.
If you're like really into her.
Did she put them on? It's not true.
I think you'd be like, maybe you're
just picky. That smells nasty.
That's like worse than be out. Do you
like that? Oh No, it's not. That's it.
A logical vios disgusting.
Especially bon a woman. Oh Christ.
The problem I have when I'm fucking
guys, I don't mind a little bit. Oh,
you know what I'm saying,
girls, that's where it is.
It's such a violent smell though.
Like any, so no, no, no petroleum.
It's such a going to be, oh my boo
is way more violent than Patrulla.
It's like old lady and roses.
Perfume.
You know like they walk
by and you're almost like,
I got a headache now from that smell. Well
that's strong, but truly I like a mile.
But you'll hear there's be, oh that's,
that's right. I mean, you know,
everyone knows their own, but like you
ever get like in a cab and you're like,
whoa man.
I remember I worked in the real estate
office in Boston like right after college
and there were these
guys could pay everyone.
Boston has like just nothing but
apartments and nothing but red all day.
Just tell you get a trapping.
But boy does, it has to.
Everyone has beo.
There were these three guys,
these guys would come in and when
they came in everyone was like, whoa.
As they walked in the door, like
what the fuck? Oh, these three guys.
As soon as they left, we would take the,
like the Febreeze. I was like for breeze,
deliberate though the new, but then what
happened was they would be, you know,
they needed to check out apartments.
So whoever lost the bet
in the office at the time,
we'd have to take them in their
car because they, you know,
they're going to be in your car.
You have to get it detail.
So people will be like, no fucking
way. No. Like you would, you would try,
you do whatever you want.
You could to not get these dudes
or any guys like them in your car.
It's always thought it was always dude,
smell like that, fucking that strong.
I had a kid in school, uh, and
when, when I lived in Florida,
it was like the first
stinky kid that I remember.
He turned out to be a real nice
kid. It was, he's a sad case.
He had been burned in a fire when he
was young. Jesus, yeah, not totally,
but one of his ears was pretty fucked
up and he was like really insecure about
it.
And um,
we actually got in some sort of a physical
altercation and I don't remember what
the thing was,
but I remember we had to go to
the teacher's office and um,
I remember it wasn't like super violent.
We didn't like beat each other up,
like maybe like pull each other's
clothes or something like that.
Cause we were like 11. And, um, when
we went to the teacher's office or the,
you know, the principal's office, we
got to sit down and talk about it. The,
the principal asked us both what had
happened and neither one of us was really
mad and, but when we decided to like
can you guys shake hands and be friends,
he was like so eager to shake hands
and be friends. I realized that like,
Oh this poor fucking guy man,
he smells bad and he's got a burnt ear
and he probably just didn't have any
friends. Like the reason why
he was douchey was probably
just wanted some sort of
attention.
Like I remember thinking that at the tide.
Like his overwhelming,
like I told him,
I didn't think he was
going to sucker punch me.
I didn't think I was going to say, yeah,
let's be friends and they would, you know,
till we get outside pitch.
It wasn't any of that but it was like
he really wanted to be friends. Yeah.
And so I remember we shook hands
and we like gave like a shake,
shake hands hug thing and we were cool
with each other. From then on out,
but that poor bastard stock.
Yeah.
I don't know if his parents
didn't take care of them.
If he was scared to bathe or if you know,
maybe it's amazing the way
smells a stick in your memory
forever.
They do.
Like you remember like how good
something smelled somewhere or something.
You know, you smell it
again and you're like, oh,
that takes me back to exactly this point.
You remember it.
And then a s a smelly mother. Like I can
smell those dudes in Boston right now.
I want to get out of here.
I want to leave where cats or pets
you stop smelling cats or boxes.
I just put down my cat that I talked
about last time I was on the show and for
my first time in 17 years, I get to
have a house that has no litter box. Oh.
And I don't even know what that's like.
Well, you're lazy too. I don't think he,
oh yeah. It's like, oh, once a week. Just
throw it in the letterbox. Oh my God.
See that's the problem.
You have to do that every day.
Otherwise you're breathing shit. Did
you hire a maid paneling fumes? I,
I've had a made, uh, right now I don't
have it. You've got to get it made.
Watching one of those top was made.
So they have one that you did that I tried
to, I told you that you did try that.
Yeah. How'd it go? It's
not good. It's bad.
It was like an older man and his,
her daughter I think.
And you can't choose who you get
to. Not Topless. Why? I don't know.
There's like a few different
companies, but when I did, I just,
there's a van parked down my street so
I just called it and I can just gawking
like you rub maps, massage pose. Right.
Why wouldn't you do at least do a
fine Yelp review? It said 99 bucks.
I wasn't really thinking into it and
like I didn't think like, oh wait,
I have to watch them clean because when,
when a maid's it and I'm like one of
the guys that hides cause I'm so ashamed
I'm right. But then like you just kind
of stand there in the kitchen going up.
If she's topless, what, this is stupid,
what am I doing this she really cleaning
or they do a bad job? No, they're,
they're,
they're just doing,
they're just regular mates
that are getting an extra
20 bucks to take their top
off I think because these are,
these are people that are like,
they seem like they were related and
it seemed like just normal mates.
It was very, very uncomfortable.
I kind of like it. I felt very bad
because it was like sad.
This was an older woman like oh
50 and maybe his or her daughter.
That's maybe, are you sure
with her daughter? It seemed
like a mom and daughter.
It was really fucked up. Well, you know,
you gotta think if you know someone that's
really fucked up and they have a kid,
that kid's going to grow
up with a fuckup parent.
Like if someone's like
really crazy or you know,
if someone is a top was made for living,
they don't think there's
anything wrong with it.
And then you know your daughter hits
18 she's like, mom, I want to join.
The top was made business. You're
like, hey, it's good enough for me.
Why isn't it good enough for you?
The mom was a little over. Very true.
Then mom was a little overweight,
but she had a humongous Mexican
tits and when she took her bra off,
it had the most horrific stretch marks
from our broad digging into her patients.
Yeah, it was. It looks like, talk to
her like when she took her tits out. No,
I just sat there and it both
just put it in a bucket.
Like they just put their clothes.
They didn't,
we didn't list it like they didn't talk
or anything. They didn't say like, hello.
They said hello when we came in,
but there were not any English or like,
I was just like the kitchen living room.
I only had,
hadn't cleaned the kitchen
living room in the bathroom.
I namely let them go and I shouldn't
say huge Mexican tits or something like
that. They speak uncomfortable. They
speak English, right? Barely. They like,
I remembered that they asked where the
vacuum cleaner was and it was very like
clean, not have you looked
under your huge Mexican tits?
I would always wonder like
what is that life like?
I would have to ask them questions.
I would give them extra money just
to be able to ask them questions.
I'll say I'll pay you for a whole extra
hour if you sit down for another five
minutes. Just let me, how was the,
how was the daughter attractive?
The daughter wasn't bad but she was a
little chubby or also like they were both
a little chubby but the mom's
boobs were weird cause they had,
she had like the huge like hanging ones
and she was cleaning the kitchen and I
just, I would like just kind
of walk in and just be like,
oh this is going on in here and it here.
Just dirty boobs. Like touching the oven.
Oh he's cleaning it. You
have minutes. I'm very sad.
It's nothing exciting. It was
horrible. I do not recommend it.
I just would want to talk to them
and find out what that's like.
Like the guys like try to attack you
like that seems like a dangerous kid.
That's why they do it though cause there's
so they weren't very appealing and it
was sad that I think it was like a
onetime thing. I would rather pay.
It was a one time for them.
I think once you get it you're not
going to have them come back ever again.
You know what I mean? It's
like it's almost a joke. One
time thing for you. Yeah.
Go one time thing for them. Would you
pick I would rather do for 20 extra bucks,
get a regular made,
but I could be bottomless and
they would not like get mad at me.
Like I would just sit in there with
normal mates and just have no pants on it.
That'd be better.
Right.
I think that's illegal.
That's what I'm saying.
The agreement is I don't
have to have where parents,
well I'm sure someone can
do that. Brang sure. That's,
well you have to want to have
your pants off with them too.
So they'd have to be like
at least somewhat attractive
lead to stroke and just
follow them around,
but they can't call it root cause then
you would get in the way and your little
narrow hallway and accidentally come
on them. I know I work in this city.
You could definitely work. Work out
your fantasy. That's a minor request.
You could work out some pretty
crazy shit in this town. Definitely.
Have you heard about this movie?
The Jinx, this, this show on Hbo?
I'm all caught up,
man.
Do you know the reopen that
guy's case because of that show?
Um, I did not know everybody that doesn't
know what the show's all about. Well, it,
there's uh,
a gentleman named Robert Durst
who is part of the Durst family,
which is a,
he was an air,
the Durst family was one of the biggest
five biggest real estate families in New
York.
And um,
he was sort of even growing up
kind of the outcast son, um,
mother died, committed suicide or
fell, uh, when he was really young.
And basically in, in the late
seventies, early eighties,
his wife Kathleen disappeared,
um, and disappeared.
Nobody has, even up to this day,
no one's up with the finder.
He was never formally charged.
People thought he had something
to do with it and I'm no trace.
He gave a lot of different
accounts to the police,
to investigators of what happened the
last time you saw her the last time we
spoke to her.
So all of these kinds of things that
don't match up that mark make you make it
sound pretty suspicious.
Um, so when the case wasn't,
it didn't progress anymore.
A few years later,
his best friend at the time was a woman
named Susan Berman and she was set to
talk to investigators when they
reopened the case this time in the,
I would say, I think we're talking like
into the nineties now. Um, so it, it,
it had a lot of time had passed and they,
investigators wanted to talk to Susan
Berman who had been Durst best friend in
whom there was a a long line of track
record of him giving her money over the
years. And you know, from his account it's
like, it's a, it's a good friend of mine.
I just always gave her money. But she
collected a substantial money from him.
Well,
the day before an investigator was
flying out from New York to see her,
she was murdered in her
house in Benedict Canyon.
So it was like kind of the second person
involved or close to Robert Durst who
died. How much money did he give her?
Well, there was, they found that like,
you know, like in, in one
of her, one of her journals,
she kept tracked of like loans or gifts.
People had given her money and
recently he had given her 50 grand,
you know, so, and the way
that they piece it together,
they think that over the years she's
collected much more than that. So it was,
she's, um, you know,
was his friend who was always kind of
struggling and he was always giving her
money. So, you know, from his, from
his side of the story, I'm rich,
I give my friend money, um, from people
that are more suspicious of it, it's,
here's money to never open
your fucking mouth. Wow. Um,
so he allegedly gets her whacked that
that's one of the things now hurt.
She has a pretty interesting story because
her father was a big time mafia guy.
Her Dad was real close with
Bugsy Siegel and was in,
in the heyday of Vegas being run with the,
by the mob.
Her Dad was one of the major players.
So people who say it's not Durst related,
we'll say that it's related to a book
she wrote where she kind of laid out a
bunch of stuff about the mob and like
her dad's role in things and all these
people. So they say, you know,
oh, it's, it's, it's very
much in line with a mob hit.
So that there's that.
And then a few years after
that, um, well right when,
you know, they, they,
that they knew that we were going
to reopen this investigation. Um,
he wanted to go into hiding.
So he moved to Galveston,
Texas and he just started
living as a mute woman.
So he wore a wig and he wore a dress
and he started renting an apartment in
cash. He paid like a year up front and
he knew he couldn't mask his voice,
so he pretended to be a mute woman,
so he would only write down things.
And he eventually developed a friendship
with the guy across the hallway from
him named Morris Black, who was
just like this old curmudgeonly guy.
And basically fast forward,
um,
in the Galveston Bay of fishermen fines,
a floating bag and it
has an arm and a leg.
And then the,
basically the police come and they find
chopped up body and they find an ID and
they're able to get fingerprints
and it's more, it's black.
So it's the guy that was across the hall.
So they go to his apartment and they
see across the hall is this woman who's
living there, who's not there at
the time. And uh, you know, they,
they find that like the, there's,
there's blood on the floor, just kind of,
you know, all the telltales of
that. Like something happened here.
And what ends up ended up happening
was that he was charged with murder.
He posted bail and then he
went on the run. Um, and, uh,
he actually got caught
shoplifting a sandwich. Um,
when he was after he had jumped bail and,
uh,
in his car they found 38,000 in cash
flow and he had 500 in his pocket.
Like he just shoplifted
for the, for the, you know,
they didn't want to pay for the sandwich.
That's how he got caught
after he jumped bail,
then he gets charged with murder.
He doesn't deny murdering.
The guy says it was self defense,
but he also chop the guy's body up,
like cut off his arms, cut off his legs,
cut off his head, put them in bags,
threw them in the bay. Oh, not guilty.
Jury decides not guilty. So, uh, you know,
so he admits to killing a person.
Yeah.
Chopping them up and not
guilty. And you know, there's,
there's a lot of people that like, that
swear that he, you know, or three people.
Let's go three people. Yeah. So it
makes sense. If he's killed one,
they caught him red handed, killing
one and cutting up the body. Yeah,
that's deep shit. That's something
you do on your third body bodies.
You light on fire this case. Are
they going there? They've read it.
That's the thing in this
country, there's, you know,
there's no statute of
limitations on murder. So you,
um, you know, I think this,
the show went into so much
detail about, uh, so he's also,
Susan Berman was 2001
a nutty motherfucker.
He notes the craziest part and just
in the, in the interviews on the show,
on the jinx, his eyes look black.
They looked like a dirty man.
They look like demon arts specifically
the entire time he's being interviewed.
And like you look and they
cut back to the, the guy who,
because they made a movie
about the Galveston story. Uh,
I think Ryan Gosling started.
He's like, it's pretty good movie.
That guy who directed that film made this
documentary and they're in this hotel
and the back and forth. Every time
they cut to his eyes are like this.
It looks like a fucking, like a, what's
it called? Like from like drag me to hell.
It's like slither in the Harry Potter,
like snake got,
you're like Jesus Christ as their
no. Eichler. Hey, it's pitch black.
What's The a Ryan Gosling
movie? Um, I don't know. I
don't remember the name. It's,
it's a good movie that
kind of, you know, in a,
that takes you through
the story pretty well.
And actually Durst liked the film so much.
That's why he agreed to do this
series with this guy. All good things.
All good things. Oh my God. Yeah. He
liked it so much that he agreed to do.
And then that movie does,
he chopped the guy up.
I can't remember if he does it in
the, in the Gosling movie, but um,
yeah, it has Gosling Gosling
playing him. Wow. But, um,
I think he probably would because,
you know, he really did that.
He had missed it doing that.
What the fuck my, yeah. Yeah.
He's, he's, uh, he's in, uh,
there's a, there's a detective on
the jinx that says it best. He goes,
I don't think that Robert Durst,
uh,
is like somebody who
takes pleasure in killing.
I don't think he's like
a bloodthirsty guy,
but I think if you corner him and you,
you make them feel threatened about
something, he'll kill you. And I was like,
I think there's probably accurate. It's
also, when you think about this guy,
he's, how old is he now?
Like 70 older. He's gotta be,
he's gotta be late seventies late
seventies early eighties yeah, I think so.
Think about this guy he grew up in,
you know, what does that mean? He was
born in the forties yeah, he's here.
He has to be, you have his age,
it's gotta be, so let's, uh,
let's just say, let's just say the forties
yeah. So he's born in 43? Yeah. Okay.
There you go. So he's born in the
forties so he grows up, you know,
when he's seven, it's 1950. You can
basically do anything back then. True.
There was no fucking fingerprints.
There's no DNA. And if you're rich,
when did they figure out finger breath?
Find that out.
One finger is to solve crimes.
I'm guessing the turn of the century,
I'm guessing 19 hundreds. I
might be wrong about nine, 1940.
I say 1876 for fingerprints either way.
1892 1,802 but Bam. Um, either way, uh,
I think that those people that grew up
then they had like a different sense of
like what you'd get away with. I
think so too. That and money. Yeah.
Oh yeah. Because of money. Money,
especially if you're talking to, I mean,
we've been,
everybody says now you know,
somebody with money can do what they
want, get it. Wait, but back in the day,
that's what that is truly reality.
If you come from a lot of money
and you destroy something,
if you ruin somebody's, you kill
somebody. They're like, well, you know,
you have a lot of money, so yeah, we're
going to, we're going to pay for shit.
Peanut lumped them shekels.
Yeah. And when he was doing this,
like when he was living in Galveston,
Galveston, he had that apartment.
He was still rich. Right. Rich as fuck.
Just, you know, showing the money.
Uh, he could still access money.
I mean, when he got arrested,
he called his wife who,
cause he's married now and
remarried someone who was
living in New York and they,
you know, this is Galveston, Texas, and
they're like, bail is set at 250 grand,
which is, you know, you, that's what you
got to pay. And he's like, cool. He calls,
he's like,
you need a 250,000 and then living in
an apartment because he wanted to be off
the grid.
He wanted to be,
he wanted nobody to notice
him because he knew the,
that investigation had just
fired up again. Which you know,
is not normally how innocent people
act. Yeah. Especially living as a woman,
mute woman in Texas. Yeah. Why don't
you just go to another country?
That's a good question.
Yeah.
I know he still had access to some
money because paid that in full.
That's two 50 gone when he
jumped bail. And then, uh,
he hired a team of lawyers, like
they were like, this is the best,
this is the best defense lawyer
in Texas criminal defense lawyer.
And so is this guy. And he
was like, cool. Both. Whoa.
Hate them each 600 grand to defend
him on this case and they got him off.
They got him off Jesus.
I wonder what the what,
what could they have said that makes it
okay to chop somebody up and throw them
in the ocean. You know about it takes
up a lot of space in your house.
Ladies and gentlemen, this is a mute
woman we're talking about. Okay. This man,
he didn't know my client
could defend himself.
He thought he was attacking a mute woman.
Imagine if that was your Mama.
Imagine it was your grandmom and this
bloodthirsty fucking savage of Jewish
descent.
I say some shit like that.
Tries to fuck your grandma. Your mute
grandma can't even cry out for help. Any,
any. All him jury Jewish. Yeah.
I didn't think sending y'all on the jury
have a grandma that you love dearly and
you don't want some hooligan. Fucking
her and some strange Galveston apartment.
If you ain't a Jew,
you must acquit cheap.
Yeah, it's pretty intense. I wonder
what, what would the argument be like?
How could they, they got to say the
guy was trying to kill them. Yeah,
they show it. Um, I'm trying to remember.
Uh, they showed him the documentary. Yeah.
Yeah. Oh, there's a lot of footage from
the trial. Wow. Yeah. I need to hear it.
I need to hear what like what the hell
could episode four has all that stuff.
It's great.
It's when they read not guilty,
they have the camera on him and he's
like, keeps turning. He's like, no,
they said not guilty and he's
like, you sure? And they're
like, yeah, yeah, not good.
He's like, Gosh, thank God.
It must feel amazing. Yeah.
That's kind of like you're about to go to
jail after he chopped it dude up. Like,
like, what are the odds?
How can I get off this?
How great would it be if they say
not guilty? He goes, that's three.
He walks out and fucking gang signs
of the camera's on the way out.
Have you seen the a shook night footage?
No, I haven't. I wanted to see it, but I
was on a plane yesterday.
Yes. We'll show it.
We can't show it on the air because
it's very, very, very disturbing.
If you want to see it yourself,
they have footage of shook night running
over those guys. And it's an accident,
right? No, just she, you need to see it.
There's no accident involved in this.
This is not an accident.
Is there a live leak
version or did you sit down?
Billy got captured on Security Cam.
No. Yeah. So here's shook night.
He pulls up. Yeah. Apparently
they were filming the, the um,
there's bone Nwa film.
Yeah. So this dude shows up,
but it looks like there's some
kind of something going on here.
And the guy had a gun. Look, I'm sure
some people were threatening him.
I'm sure there was some shit going on.
But note what actually happens like this,
this part is not a God damn accident.
Look at that. Bam. And then watch us.
This is hard. This is hard to
watch. Oh. Oh, oh, that guy is dead.
The first guy lived, the second guy.
The first guy lived. Yeah. Yeah.
That's why they blurt out the second guy,
the spots,
because that guy just
got murdered. Wow. Yeah.
Like he's moving them around.
That's good. And then this guy,
he's a gospel possible gun and
sticks it in his back. Yeah.
Most likely it wasn't gun.
Yeah.
He might've pulled a gun out on Shugg
night and chug night drove over him.
I mean, that's what it looks like to
me. I mean, look, somebody ran it.
I ran out to him. Hey you, you son
of a gun. It was like some movement,
like he was a great,
yes,
the other truck moves or the grabbing
each other or something. Fucking name.
That's unbelievably hard to watch.
So you think sugar definitely did it
to murder. Not just like freak out,
like get me the fuck out of here and he's
just gone. Well it could be that too,
but look at this, watch this, Bam. And
he didn't try to go around that dude.
He went over him and ran that
guy over. Yeah, that's true.
That guy was getting run over,
which is what most of us would do.
Some pointed a gun at us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Did you see
what TMZ released today? Uh,
footage from like four years ago.
When he was with Kat Williams and he did
the exact same thing where he just went
through a crowd of people in his
SUV. Uh, I, they just put it on,
it's on the front page of TMZ today.
They did, he hurt anybody through,
let me check it cause I didn't even look
actually watching the video. Just solid.
They did a documentary on him.
The guys guy's been through a lot of shit.
That's it.
She's just got shot earlier this year too.
I mean it's like a real live
gangster. Yeah. Living amongst us.
Bad Shit happens though.
Wherever he is. Oh yeah. Yeah.
You don't want to be around every
time he's at the comedy store. I,
I legit gets scared like I, I'm, I'm, he,
cause he used to come there a lot. He's,
he attracts, you know, that guy has a,
has a legacy of wrong doing
and just bad people around.
Like if you're in a room with him
that something bad's going to happen.
I kind of amazing that he, up until
this point was still out in the street,
you know? Yeah. And he's served, you
know, significant time before. Like he's,
yeah,
well this is the last thing.
When he got shot apparently really
fucked him up pretty bad. It just,
he just struck, striked one person
last time you went to Iraq and uh,
and he doesn't say anything about if the
person died or anything. Jesus Christ.
Yeah, Dude. Yeah. It's weird.
It's weird when you find out about those
guys that are still out there and you
go really in 2015, this really obvious
bad guys still running around out there.
Yeah. He's like a villain, right?
He's like a movie villain. Look,
imagine if John Gotti was
alive and out there running,
running around in little Italy mocking
people the way he did back before they
arrested him. It, it's pretty crazy. That
was a weird one. That's like a movie.
Well the John Gotti one was a lot like
a movie because here was a guy and the
celebrate the parades and
the streets from this,
from the neighborhood your works
and all that kind of crazy shit.
And everybody loved the neighborhood
because it was, everybody was safe.
You know why this guy was the dawn?
Yeah.
He would walk around and he's like super
expensive suits and laugh and always
look confident as hell. Big, thick fucking
neck. Let trying to fuck with me. Yeah.
It was all like, like they're just bugging
the guy for no reason. That was my,
it's favorite quote of mine is that,
uh,
like after it was all said and done and
he said all I ever wanted was a good
sandwich. That was, that's what he
said. That's what this is all about.
This could have been resolved so much
easier if we just went to a deli. Hey,
just give me a sandwich
sandwich. Salami. Well,
Putin is kind of that guy, but way bigger,
way bigger scale. He's, yeah. You know,
and he's kind of that guy in Russia.
Yeah. I mean, he just killed his fucking,
an adversary or somebody
killed his adversary,
some guy who was the leader of the
whatever other party over for us and that,
you know, like there's net, you know,
they arrested people and one of the guys
blew himself up. Blew himself up. Yeah.
They got to the guy's apartment,
he blew himself up.
And there's never going to be a real
investigation in this and in Russia today
of like the, you know, you
know, it's connected to him.
Like the order came down.
You think so I don't think
they'll put it together. No,
not cause they're not capable.
It's just that more people would
have ended up getting shot.
You definitely think it was
Putin's ideally kill that.
It's his idea. You're not,
there's not going to be a recording
of him saying it, but you know,
his camp is like, yeah, for
sure. I'm reserving judgment,
but it certainly looks that way.
What's really fascinating to me, uh,
one of the things that's
really fascinating to me is
that this is only one thing
that they do. That's insane. Yeah.
But there's other things they
do that's insane with super,
super rich people where they
accused him of a crime. They go in,
they take their businesses,
they take all their money and they
put them in jail and they did this,
this really rich,
wealthy Russian oligarch,
and they had him in jail for a long time.
Man. And they recently released him.
I think he was in jail for like more than
eight years, if I remember correctly.
But I remember the story getting out.
I'm like,
this is the most insane story
I've ever heard in my life.
This guy was some wealthy
oil guy was worth, you know,
billions us dollars and they just
came in and took this guy's business,
put him in jail. And that's what
they've done it several times.
It's not a onetime thing they do. They
just go in there, whatever the dispute is,
they just decide that you an enemy of
the state or your, uh, you know, you,
your trees in whatever
crime they doctor up,
slap your ass in jail,
take all of your money and they just
leave you in jail for a long time.
It's horrific. It's insane.
Yeah. And I imagine too,
like if you're just a regular citizen,
like you can't,
how scary that is to live there.
And you think like, well, you know,
start talking about it. Like, make
us think about it. And it's like, no,
you really don't like,
then you also get thrown in jail or worse.
You can't, you can't even speak up about
it. You know, we don't, we don't really,
we don't comprehend that,
that feeling that it must be to
completely live in fear. Yes.
And it's not that the,
this, this, without a doubt.
There's some organizations in
this country, they don't even,
you don't have to name them that have
done horrific shit too to US citizens.
They've done, people have been murdered.
Things have happened for sure. Right.
We all agree that, but it's nowhere near
the scale of it is right now in Russia.
Like whatever corruption you
might think there is an American.
I would agree with you.
There's a lot of corruption,
but nothing compared to what's going on
in Russia. No, Russia is nuts, man. Yeah.
That reminds me of like, I mean I, I had
a lot of Cuban friends when I lived in,
in south Florida. Like all their
stories of their parents were like that,
that like, you know,
yeah, Castro just there.
Like we had this successful whatever,
these stores,
and he just took our stores,
took our shit, and I was like,
it's not yours anymore.
Yeah. What the fuck? Well,
that's what happens when you've got a guy
who was essentially like a king. Yeah.
I mean, he's an emperor. I mean,
he's like an emperor Russia. Yeah.
That's really what he's like,
right? Yeah. Yeah. It's terrifying.
What does that guy's life like?
What do you think of reality
show following Putin around
for a day would be like,
imagine if he,
if he just decided to allow cameras to
follow him around for a year and just
show how he actually runs shit. If
he gets so crazy and he's like, look,
I'll just show you all of it. You
want to see what we do? Oh yeah,
this guy is talking a lot of shit
about me, so we're going to kill him.
And then they sent some guys out and
they'd gun some dude down and everybody
goes, okay, who's going to, who's going to
do something about this? Nobody. Nobody.
We're going to do something
about that. It's like, what the,
what would the United States do?
We thoroughly, what did they say?
They say we thoroughly disagree with Mr
Putin's decision to murder his biggest
critic literate. We say, yeah, it would,
it would be the complete
of bullshit statement.
Of course they didn't do anything of
course that, and if we did do something,
then they would start talking shit about
what, well, what about your drones?
What happened today was a
terrible tragedy. And we, uh,
we respect anyone's right to express
themselves and say what they say and
critique whomever they want to critique.
The,
the solution is not dumping
their body in rivers. Thank you.
Bring them up fat and then
dumping the body in rivers.
Yeah. It's, it's insane, man.
I think a lot of his actions too, or
it's all based in fear too, you know?
But like tough guy things.
People think they're like,
that guy's just this violent,
crazy guy and they're all just scared.
More scared. The Russian
version. KGB. KGB. Yeah. Yeah.
And he's, he's still looking
pretty good at 62 years old.
He looks like the guy that you would think
of when you think of like a dangerous
leader of a foreign country like Russia,
dangerous like hawk,
like and know military
shirtless on horseback. Yeah.
That's the way to fucking roll.
Well that was one of the things that,
what the fuck is his name? Um, uh,
the dude from the Bourne identity,
handsome bastard, Matt Damon, Matt Damon.
Matt Damon had said about Sarah Palin.
It was hilarious when he was talking
about, it's like Sarah Pailin and uh, her,
you know, Witty charm, you
know, getting to a folksy charm.
I think the term you use getting to become
vice president with a guy is old as,
uh, what the fuck is
his name? John Mccain.
John Mccain was like in
his seventies already,
right when he's running for
president or at least close to it.
Like if he dies and then
she could possibly be across
the table from Putin. Yeah.
They were talking about sailor Sarah
Pailin and Putin sitting down. Well, Vlad,
I gotta tell Ya I what you're doing.
Oh, America is just wrong in America.
She's not going to stand for it.
I'll tell you right now,
the land of free home of the brave, he
would probably just her right there on TV,
just punch her in the face and everybody
scattered down the road goes back for
her. Oh my God. It could be world war
three. Yeah. I liked that. Their culture,
like he never smiles, you know, that's
considered like goofy and week. Yeah.
Just smile at the eastern bloc. Well
he never gives you like a, yeah, no,
not like Obama.
Obama like has a wide open laughing smile.
Like he's a jolly fellow. Yeah. Yeah,
for sure. Yeah. That's considered goofy.
I wonder what they think about America.
I wonder what like the KGB type fellows
that are running Russia right now,
silly week.
Um,
guys smiled too much. Yeah,
but do you wonder like,
okay,
I wonder what they think about
the way their government works?
I wonder if there's,
like,
is there a select group of people
that all this money's getting evenly
distributed too so that everybody like
keeps her mouth shut or how many people
are wanting to kill that guy and we're
going to have to deal with the guy who
kills him someday. You know, there's
people that are all in for sure.
And I think there's a lot of people that
are just begging for things to change.
Did you see the HBO documentary recently
on um, uh, gay people in Russia?
No, that was a tremendous, there's really
a documentary how like, they're, you know,
they've written laws recently like it and
like there's these groups of guys that
are just out hunting gays and they
like to, they like to bait them.
So they put like ads and
a guy poses like a,
I want to meet you.
And then when the guy shows up,
there's like 15 people and they hold
them down and they like throw it piss on
him and they, they, uh, put them
on camera and make him like,
just mock them. It's, it's terrible.
And then they upload it and everybody
watches it in the country. So,
and a lot of times it's that guy
who they're mocking would be,
would be a guy in the closet and like,
we'll lose his job. Family. Well,
they just humiliate them. It's,
it's, it's brutal. It was brutal.
What do you think that is?
Like what is this all of a sudden,
especially what does this
new attention on gay people?
I think it's because there's been a
lot of progress with gay gay rights and
especially in the last 10 years.
So when something like that's coming
more to the forefront, you go like, dude,
this can't, you know, the
people that don't want it, the,
the super homophobic people are going
to act the way that they're acting.
There's so scared that this is going
to be the norm and that we're going to
treat them like human beings maybe
even hear that. They're like, no. Like,
so they, you know, they started
these organizations like, uh, better,
better family today group.
You know,
it's like we can't let these people
be teachers and, and you know,
just live in our apartment buildings.
They're, they're pariahs. Yeah. So they,
you know, they associates all the old
shit like all gay people are pedophiles,
like all that shit. So, but that is
like thriving and huge in Russia.
Not just thriving, but they're, they're
making laws against it. Yeah, man.
They're making laws act like imagine
if someone tried to actively make laws
against gay people today
in the United States,
there would be a huge uproar
throughout the country.
What kind of uproars or in Russia?
I think it's one of those things
where it's like, it's very,
it's really rare to speak up against that.
I think more people are probably in
fear of saying something then doing what
they know is the right thing to do. You
know? That's the thing too is like you, I,
you have to empathize a lot with the
person who you know is in that situation
who's not siding with that but lives
in that kind of culture or you're like,
are you going to speak up?
Like when you know what the
response is going to be, you,
you want to say yes and you want
to be like, yeah, of course.
But it's a scary thing in a,
in a,
in an environment like that
to speak up and be like, no,
I'm going to say something.
Wasn't that Pussy Pussy riot
went to jail for as well?
I think one of the things that went
to jail for was protesting against the
treatment of gays and
Russia. I think so, yeah.
That's one of the things where she was,
or they were inside of a church like
there. Yeah. They did it on a church,
but one of the things they did
there were inside a church. Yeah.
There was another one they did.
They got beaten by belts.
Did you ever see that one? Oh,
there's footage of that. Fine.
These soldiers show up security people,
whatever they were, and they're, they're,
they're like literally beating
these girls with belts with like,
like a whip thing, dude. Yeah.
He just beat the fuck out of him.
Yeah. Me and it was when they were
protesting or I'll pull it up.
Pussy riot protests.
They were in,
the couple of them were in the new
season of house of cards. Really? Yeah.
They have a scene with the guy who's
basically playing Putin on the show. Yeah,
it's pretty, it's pretty, yeah.
That show's phenomenal. Yeah.
I need to wash that place
or watch that show rather.
I still haven't really have to start over
and touched it from the beginning and
it's one thing for sure. I had to give
up on homeland last night. No good.
The new season is the beginning
of it was just balling me out.
This chick is a thing about house of
cards is you got to give it a few,
but once you get started,
like it's your rope,
then yeah. This is when they get
beaten. What? Yeah, look there.
They put on their math. They just
masks I guess, and they do this thing.
Know like they're, they're dancing and
they'd come over and they get maced.
See the cops come over and may sum and
then they'd beat the shit out of him.
Look at this. These belt
things. Oh, whipping them. Shit.
They just start fucking them up.
He just put his weapon at camera,
man to everybody and everybody.
This is because they're
kicking everybody's ass and
they're doing it like while
they're being filmed. They
don't give a fuck. You know,
you imagine if this was happening in
America, like kicking him and shit.
They kicked her when she's down,
man, this is a security people there.
This is like,
they're not even hiding the
fact that this is their thugs.
Yeah.
This is like total thug shit.
They're kicking people in
their dow whipping them.
It's not like security guards in
America where policing in America,
if they did shit like that, they would
get reprimanded. They would like, Hey,
your violence is inappropriate violence.
But if they sprayed them with the,
they're allowed to spray him.
You hit him with a tear gas in the face.
You can do a few things
as far as restrain them.
You can't kick them and whip him like
that. It's pretty intense, man. I've seen,
I saw footage older like,
but like still modern day or like
rushing cops do not fuck around. Like,
and I mean like not for even just
like this, like standard crime stuff.
Like, if you're actually going after
a guy who's whatever, you know,
selling drugs or something
that they would normally send,
like these cops would like jump over a
picnic table and kick a guy in the jaw.
Like to bring him down. Like they don't
fuck around. I saw footage of one,
a guy pulled over,
he was pulled over by the cops and the
cop like knocked on the window and the
guy got gestured and then he took a baton.
Just smashed the whole window open
while the guy at the car. Yeah.
I don't think in Moscow. You
fucking, you talked back to cops.
I don't think that it happens at
all there. It's, it's, it's uh,
it's not playing around.
Meanwhile, they live on the
same planet as us, right? Yeah.
They've been around longer than
us. Way longer than us. I mean,
what the fuck is going on in Russia?
I Dunno. That's a war torn place.
A lot of shit going on. Right. All this
crime. Do you know what's going on?
The Crimea stuff. Do you understand
that? Uh, I mean, I remember that. Um,
I mean,
I don't want to give
a bad account of it,
but like this was territory that Russia,
you know,
claimed a long time ago or what was
theirs and then they just straight up snag
that shit back from what does
the Ukraine right. And um,
huge dispute over it obviously. But
Pew Putin and Russia is like, no,
see that's where it's fucked
up to the Soviet Union.
They all used to be in the same girl
together. Yeah. They saw me together.
We're all one team and now they're
like going to war with each other.
That's like, if like we got rid of
taxes, we were like, you know what,
you guys can just beat her
own thing. Yeah. Oh, but we
want the Rio grandee. Yeah.
Get get. Yeah, that's ours. Give us, give
us that shit back. Wouldn't take it back.
Yeah. It's Texas back. We should
change our mind unchecked. I mean,
I think Putin would do and he would start
taking all kinds of places back. Yeah.
Do you think you would go to war? Would
he go to war with the United States now?
There's, I think even the
craziest person, you know,
you always have the nuclear threat and
the back of your mind and do you want all
out war? I Dunno. In this day and age
it's kind of hard to imagine, you know,
but the QMAP if it was,
if he was just like we're going to take,
I don't know if I can,
we're going to Russia.
If Russia is going to be like
we're going into Chechnya,
I'm going to fuck them up again.
Like they all like they have and take
the Republic of Georgia and all that shit
back. They say we've got a bad deal with
Alaska. We want that shit. Yeah. That was,
that's when it gets crazy.
If they find out how much oil is
in Alaska and they just decide,
I mean there's some shit
going on Antarctica like
claimings spots of land for
auto about that. I mean that
it's Russia really short. Yeah.
Cause it started down all that,
you know,
the snow caps are starting to melt and
so there's areas that are going to be
open to travel with boats that weren't,
that aren't, aren't open right now.
So they're starting to claim these
areas just because it's like old school,
you know, colonial type shit.
More war is inevitable, you know,
it's going to happen. You know what
I mean? What do you mean inevitable?
It's going on right now. But I mean
like even like whatever declines now,
it's not like that would be the end
of wars. It's just going to, yeah,
it's an endless cycle. It's
just seems like it is. Yeah.
This current design of human being
that we're, we're using. Yeah.
And the fact that, you know, we're
results in pro, like the money's made.
That's why it so much money involved in,
yeah.
You see these con like just the companies,
you know,
that that make money
does like designing a,
a ship or a rocket that the US
government likes. They're like,
this is great. We love this plane.
Billions. Billions of dollars.
Billions to you. Yeah. Make more awesome
shit. Make it go around the world.
And one second. Can you do that gun that
does what? Yeah. Yeah. You see that thing?
They have a laser, the shooting.
They can disable a car. No.
You know the shooting lasers through
the hood of a truck and just fucking
barbecues the engine.
Really? Oh, it's nuts.
Like it melts through the hood of a car.
I mean, I don't know how far it lasts.
How would the distance they're using
these things, but they aim did it.
They a test demonstration of it
and shot through an engine block.
You got that day. Look at this shit. Wow.
Fired from a mile of Lockheed Martin THC.
It's from a mile away.
Do you see the boat one where they,
it's to get off of pirates and stuff and
they shoot it a boat and it catches the
boat on fire when it's going to shore up.
Imagine what Lockheed is going to get
for that. Like when they go, well,
you say what it does. Yeah. They can
shoot through an engine block a mile away.
It's this insane. Love your laser.
He was $19 billion fucking Amen.
How weird is that?
It's incredible.
Highest power ever documented by
a laser weapon and it's tight.
New York Stock Exchange Info. First
you guys know by. Isn't that funny?
Isn't that funny? Yeah. That's what it is.
Lockheed marketing and y s
e four you know Colin Lmt?
Yeah. It shows you that's
the first fucking thing. It
shows you. That's amazing.
That's amazing. I don't want to buy some
laser style is Lockheed martin.com so,
right.
But that's a press release from the,
the one when they did the
boat and the boat. Yeah.
They can do some crazy shit now and
they're going to set those things up in
space. So they're just be in
space. Star Wars floating above us.
They're just laser beam your
fucking house into the ground.
Unbelievable drones now and with
laser beams and the future, and
I just kind of wonder,
you got to wonder if we're going to
be able to keep it together. Yeah.
It's kind of amazing.
No one's dropped a nuke since the forties
I think it's amazing that all the time
and then and that entire
administration's goals,
like the entire thing that they're,
their number one goal a lot of times
is just to keep other governments from
getting one.
That's the number one list.
Number one on the list for
dozens of governments is like,
just keep Iran from developing one. Just
keep that from happening. But meanwhile,
Pakistan ASM. Yeah. India.
India has them. Yeah.
I mean they behaviors
coordinate each other and their
neighbors. Yeah. That point.
Nukes at each other. It's
terrifying. It smells better. Whoa.
Pakistan really? And why is that? India
is more famous for their food. Right?
Indian food is way more
popular. Yeah. Curry like, and,
but I think that I have a similar
Pakistani friend who said the food is very
similar. Yeah. It's a trick
question is it stinks like shit.
How dare you don't even go over there.
You don't even know this.
You're talking shit.
You know the,
yesterday I sat next to Serena
Williams on my flight. Yeah.
I saw that on your Instagram. I keep
meeting awesome black people on planes,
like it's out of control.
What other awesome black
people that you met on planes?
Bruce, Bruce, uh, Mike Tyson. Wow.
That's where you met Mike Tyson went
playing Serena the number one my title
became your buddy, right?
Well, yeah. I mean,
do you text each other every
now and again? No, not really.
I shouldn't text is way. No, I
don't. I'm still thinking about him.
I tell him he's my thoughts. Oh,
you and my thoughts and prayers.
But uh,
but so cool dude.
The coolest and that's arguably,
you know, one of the most dominant,
if not most dominant female athlete of
this generation. One of them for sure.
She's the best. She the number one, number
one. Who's number two? Any white chicks?
Oh yeah. Mix. There's a
bunch of the Europeans,
it's all Europeans where he skis and,
and, and Europeans are always in there.
That's interesting. He's so dominant, man.
How many American female tennis players
are there that are really famous? Well,
if we're talking about over the course
of history, there's been right now,
right now I really, I really wouldn't
know. I don't know. Right. So,
but this is one of my point was,
but Serena Williams is famous as food,
but she's famous as fuck because
she's such a winner. Right.
Like she is dominant and she and you
know a lot of female tennis players,
you know, they're declined hat like
they, they peak early age wise,
you know the,
the female dominance in tennis sometimes
happens teens and early twenties and
she's 33 number one in the world still
and still winning titles. You know,
she ran from a drug test. No. Yeah,
she hit herself cause either her, her
sister Venus. Yeah. When we find out,
um, they, she ran to her a safe room.
She said she thought someone was breaking
into the house and it was a truck.
That's what you
want me to find out what it was?
Yeah, it was Serena. Yeah,
it was her. That's hilarious.
I, you know, I think
it's one of those things,
swearing Williams locks herself in panic
room and drug test mix up. Woopsies wow.
I thought you were a murderer or
are you just a lab technician?
That's hilarious. She probably knew
she had like another six hours, four,
she piss clean. She got in there
and started drinking vinegar water.
That's Hilarious, man. Hiding the safe
room. Yeah. Yeah. That is hilarious.
That's just an impressive athlete,
man. She's an impressive athlete.
I think it's one of those sports,
much like track and field that
virtually everybody is doing something.
They didn't tennis. I didn't know about
it in tennis. Really? I really didn't.
I think every competitive sports,
it's worth millions of dollars. Yeah.
I think there's so much money on the line.
I think that's what they start looking at
it. They start looking at it like, look,
we have two options here.
Either we do it and we test positive
and we get fined or something goes wrong
and we get shamed or we do it smart and
nobody ever finds out and you make more
money. Yeah. Did you watch, did you
watch that Armstrong documentary?
The one on the one on Netflix?
I remember being on this show,
uh, a few years ago
before, you know, he got,
he admitted and all that stuff
and talking badly about him and
being like [inaudible] getting a lot
of messages from people that hated you,
that were really there. Like he's
never failed a test. You fucking idiot.
And they don't email me anymore.
That's what they always say too when you
ask them if they've ever done anything,
they go, I've never failed a test.
That was his big thing. Yeah. Yeah.
Everybody says that. They always say
that I've never failed a test. Yeah.
That's not what I asked you.
Yeah.
Did you ever take anything that
enhances your performance? And I said,
I've never failed a test.
Yeah.
It's so rampant now. You're right in all
immune. The questioning. It's rampant.
Yeah. It's in football.
It's crazy. Like, yeah.
Without question. I just think it's a
part of the sport of track and field.
I think it's a part of
the sport of cycling.
It's at least appears to be
a part of the sport of MMA.
There's a guy who was running the
California Athletic Commission right now.
His name is Andy Foster and he's very
smart dude and he's doing a really smart
thing. One of the things
he's doing, first of all,
he's got a long history in martial arts.
He's actually fought himself.
He's competed,
he's been a martial artists
for a long stretch of his life.
So he's really aware of the
culture. He understands it. And uh,
he decided after this last UFC two blood
and piss test everybody instead of just
doing like the people
that are in the main car,
instead of doing the blood tests on a
select few and championship bouts cause
they're, they're really expensive. Yeah.
Like they cost as much as $40,000
for each blood test. What? Yeah,
so I don't know what the California
State Athletic Commission did when they
financed that.
I don't know how much they paid for it
and he didn't want to talk about it.
But what he does,
what did say was they were going to
do comprehensive blood screenings of
everyone that competed. And he goes, if
there's anyone that's hiding something,
we're going to find it.
And if you're hiding something that
you wouldn't detect with urine,
we're going to find it with blood.
So and so.
Most people didn't expect these
tests, so we'll see what happens. Wow.
But I mean there's been so many people
that have been caught in the UFC over the
past few months.
And then other MMA organizations,
it's pretty hard to
deny that it's an issue.
It's just how much of an issue is it is
the big question. That's true. Yeah. Yeah.
And you know,
and the more the the testing,
we'll get more complex and more advanced
and then so will the next performance
enhancing drug. You know, it,
they just keep getting better at designing
them and then they have to get better
at detecting them. But that's like,
we'll never end. No, never. And not well,
there's competitors who want to win
and there's lots of money on the line.
It will never end.
Yeah.
I think they're just going to keep
figuring out new ways to manipulate the
system. New, new bath salts. No new
creams that you rub in and yeah.
You know they make we'd bass
off. No, no. Oh yes they do.
And I'm, I mean bath salts,
like that smokey shit that he makes
me, you know, makes you crazy. Yeah.
I mean basketball is like, you put
it in the bath. Yeah, I saw you.
You say you've been taking them a lot.
You've been doing this.
I've been doing just regular bath of
Epsom salts and you don't have a tank.
The isolation tank shoots all Epsom
salt too, but it doesn't get hot.
It's really hot one. Yeah, the Bass, I get
hot and you feel much better after that.
My God, it was like everything
is so loose and relaxed.
EPSOM salts have some old school shit,
dude.
They figure that out a long time ago
and you do the cryo thing to write.
All those things are good to be
proactive with your health. Tom,
proactive with your health. I got
a them, but I look forward to it.
You got to portray that love Jesus. That's
true. A lot to talk about him a yeah,
sure. Great depth. I don't think he
talks to me. He listens to the bishop.
If he does, you got to find anybody
that my last session know some shit.
I got another guy for you. Don't
worry about it. Okay, cool.
So tell me what he does to you.
He, I'm like, we'll just be
hired a trainer working out.
He's a good trainer, knows his stuff. I
would say that works me out really hard.
I've really enjoyed it.
I've been progressing. It's
been good. Losing weight,
getting strong, all that's good. Um,
but then like he'll just drop some
Jesus Christ stuff on me sometimes.
And uh, yeah. Well, you know what I,
you know, when I started to think about,
I was like, I'd worked with
different trainers, you know,
over the course of my life. I feel like
they all have like one, like a weird,
they always have like kind of something
about their personality, you know? Yes.
Some of them will like you ask them
one thing and they'll give you their
philosophy on, you know, their, their
life philosophy and you're like, yeah,
I just went, are we doing another
set? Like you just kind of like,
you know what I mean? Like some of them
will download about their love life,
like they have quirks and him,
it'll just be like in the middle of
working out and then he'll be like, uh,
you could stop there.
Or when I went in I was like,
I had a respiratory thing and I go,
Hey,
today can we just do like heavy but kind
of not keep heart rate up really high
so I'm not breathing because my lungs
are bothering me. And he was like,
absolutely. Then we start working out
and like I'm just running all over it.
He's having me do box jumps and run and
I'm just like, thanks for ignoring me.
Like, and he goes, you know,
I, I remember you said that,
but then you know you've been fine and
like he won't let me push you too hard.
And I was like, what? And he goes like,
like if I was pushing you too hard,
Jesus will go like, Hey, like
take it easy on him. Jesus Christ,
you've got to get out of there man.
He'd go, oh, all right, so next set.
Like should we just go to the next thing?
Then?
Like I just see the thing I've learned
about people is that when you ask
questions at those moments is when
they'll really take it to the next level.
So I'm very,
uh,
aware that by engaging that part of the
conversation will lead to more of it.
So what I do normally it was when
it comes up, I just, I'll go, like,
I'll nod and be like, yeah, all right,
I'm going to do this next one and I'll
just move on because that's how it,
that part of the conversation dies. And
then it shifted to something else. Like,
like I was leaving on,
I went on like a little mini tour last
week and right before I left I was with
him and we just finished the work and I
was like, yeah, you know, um, I just, uh,
just hope I, you know, I don't
fall off too much on this week off.
That's was basically baiting
for like motivation and,
and like some type of game plan,
like tried to cardio Thursday and
maybe do, you know, this and that fry,
like that kind of thing. And
so I was like, yeah, you know,
so I just hope my progress doesn't
die down. He goes, well, you know,
we always try to do stuff on her own,
but like the thing is like if you,
if you ask Jesus for help, he'll give
it to you. And I was just like, I,
I just want to know like,
how many reps I should Friday
did you write me up a program?
And so we can put all that Jesus stuff
in there to just highlight that no one to
go. Yeah. And he goes, you know,
you don't do anything on our own.
Like he's there helping us and he loves,
when we asked for a kind of white guy,
white guy, and I go, all right, man,
it's Junky or what? Yeah, yeah,
I guess once you see, so what's
the background? Well, he's not.
And if he likes junkie x, he's just
x. Uh, adrenaline got like everything.
Adrenaline Jayke everything. But no, but
like I think drugs to haul everything.
Yeah. Yeah. Good. Nice guy too.
I met a bunch of them that are nice guy.
Very nice guy.
And you can't deny the
effectiveness of that.
Like using like a religion in your
life for a lot of people. Yes.
It does work. And I believe in it.
I think that it pro the, you know,
my whole thing is,
I think it probably does really does
work and do something for him. Yeah.
You know, and I don't,
I don't, uh, you know,
there was just something for a
lot of people. Yeah, exactly.
It doesn't mean it's real,
but it's like a placebo.
Like she should it be okay to sell
someone a sugar pill and tell them that it
cures cancer. No, but what if you do that
and it cures or cancer. Right, right.
Well, that's what religion
is for a lot of folks.
Like there's a lot of people that if
you tell them that the Lord is watching
over them and then everything's going to
be amazing, they have now that covers.
Sure, okay. As long as I pay my homage
to the Lord, pay my respects to the Lord,
I do my praying, I make sure
to do that. I'm covered.
God's going to make
sure everything's cool.
And that alone will give you like
a certain amount of relaxation.
A certain amount of a big part of why
it doesn't like really freak me out is
that my mother's pretty much exactly
like that. Oh, okay. So you know,
like she owned it.
Yeah,
she's dialed it back to
me because she's like,
you're 35 and you're still not
doing it. But she's, you know,
but like I grew up with like, you know,
rosaries everywhere, crosses everywhere.
You know, if we take a 10 minute car
ride, she was like, let's play the rosary.
And like, you know, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Either rose or, sorry, pray the rosary,
the rosary on a 10 minute car ride.
What do you do during the time that car
rides? What do you have to like, uh,
you know,
our father and then 10 hail Mary's and
then another our fathers 10 hail Mary's.
You do 50 hail Marys because it's a
10 or 15 minute car ride. Yeah, yeah.
Pray before meals pre, you know, that
kind of stuff. And then she's like,
if I tell her like, you know, hey,
this is great. I, uh, he just sold out
this show, uh, in Atlanta.
It was great. And she's like,
did you thank God? And I'm like,
I was about to, I called you,
you know,
tell you the story about how it was.
There was this girl in college
that I thought was in to me,
which was really just trying to get me
to go to one of these Christian retreats.
No. Oh, such adult. Uh,
this really hot Puerto Rican girl
who wore glasses. She was really,
she was really sexy and a,
I was so,
I had no idea what was going on.
I thought like,
this girl wants me to join
her and her friends and party.
So we're all hanging out.
Um,
we're in class and she was constantly
trying to get me to go to these things and
I couldn't do it because back then,
a lot of times I was fighting
and tournaments. So I was, uh,
talking to her and um,
no,
no subject of religion.
No, no topics were brought.
It was just normal lifestyle, religion,
never even, it was never, hey,
come out to these parties, we're going
to have a Christian get together. Um,
it was just normal talk.
And then one day we were at a
cafeteria during lunch and I came in,
I sat down and I said, did you guys hear
that there was a plane crash landed, uh,
at the airport? And they're
like, oh no. What happened?
Was anyone hurt? And I go, no,
no, the, the front landing gear
didn't go down and it had a skid,
but everybody's fine. And so they all
go, praise God. Oh, praise God. I want
all of them. Oh No. And then I
just started like, Oh, you idiot.
You thought she thought you were hot.
She's just trying to suck you
into the calls. Yeah. And so I go,
praise God, he think God had something
to do with that. It was just like the,
if God was around, like why would he
make the landing gear come back out?
Like why would he just make everybody
be okay because the landing gear didn't
work, wouldn't he fix the landing
gear? So everybody didn't die.
He likes mechanical things. He does
stuff. And I forget what the response was,
but there were, there were
very upset with me. And uh,
we got into this religious conversation.
So I'm like,
so you guys are like super religious and
like I had to know like what was going
on. So I go, so what are these
parties, what you guys do? Well,
we get together and we talk about the
Lord and we like to bring other people
into the Lord so they understand
how we feel about the Lord.
Because a lot of people,
they just don't have exposure to the Lord.
And I was like, oh dammit.
Yeah, he won't choose hot.
I think she was dirty when she was younger
and she's trying to make up for the
dirty cause she has smelled like sex
and I don't mean like snagajob. Yeah,
I mean like she was like sexy God and
she was like the little coyote that they
would put out that's in heat and tricks
dogs to going out into the woods and the
other coyotes jump them and eat them.
That's what she was really, yeah. Glasses,
sexy recruiting dudes.
Just ways would you cut?
It was like down the Cape.
So it was like a significant trip.
You'd had to go and stay with them and
hang out for the weekend. And I was like,
what are you guys going to
do when we have this party?
It's going to be really amazing.
A lot of our friends come down.
I sat next to a girl on a flight who,
a book about Saint Peter and I was like,
oh, we started talking about the book and
then we started talking about, you know,
Christ. And she was, she was, I started
asking her more questions and she goes,
yeah, you know, like, um, I just came
to this kind of conclusion. There was,
it was difficult, but like, if
you don't accept Christ, you know,
like you'll definitely go to
hell. And I go, uh, I go, well,
one of my first thoughts, if you, if
you were to say that, it would be like,
what about like all the Jews and
Muslims in the world? And she goes,
they're going to hell.
And I was like, Jesus,
that's really intense. I know you
think they all go to hell. She goes,
unfortunately, unless they, uh, accept
Christ, they will. And I was like,
what a fucking crazy reality
to have in your head. Wow.
That's the reality that you walk around
with you everywhere you go. Like,
excuse me. You, you must listen to
me. You must listen to me. Yeah.
Maybe you know me.
My name is Kirk Cameron,
and I'm here to tell you that if you
don't listen to me and listen to Lauren,
you're going to go to hell.
That's fry.
There's no air conditioning and his
fucking, this is going to be demons.
They stick pork forks up your asshole.
So it going to go to hell. Yeah.
When you take it there, it's like,
all right, let's be done with this.
Have you ever seen that?
There's an ancient Italian painting
that's on the roof of some cathedral and
it's all like the,
the,
the rooftop painting represents like a
heaven and all the way down to hell and
the outskirts like the,
the bottom layer represents a hell and
there's actual demons and people that are
down there getting tortured by demons in
the painting and the demons are shoving
like pitchforks ups up people's asses now.
Yeah.
Jamie, you'll find it. Look at this
Sistine Chapel, Sistine Chapel.
That's an assistant.
That's the Sistine chapel dude.
Those are demons and it's just one of
them. I mean there's the, the, they exist.
These kinds of images exist on
several different paintings. Look,
fucking demons and how
they're getting dragged.
Whoa.
I don't even know if that's the only one.
I don't cause I don't see the pitch fork
up the ass one. There's another one.
Check to see if we can find some other
ones, but we get that demon men now.
What are you waiting for?
Come.
There's no rule book or in the middle
where the like that happens. Then you go,
okay. Okay. Okay. I except I, I'm with you
now. Nope. Too late. God dammit. I mean,
sorry. Well, it's because it was written
by morons. Like it doesn't make any sense.
It doesn't make no sense.
Why would God only tell those people?
How about tell us too.
If God came down and told us how to live,
we would all be like, okay, yeah,
you're right there. Now we know. Oh,
we have to be told by our
grandparents called having faith.
That's what you always
get the faith thing. Oh,
by the way, another awesome black person
when I got Michael's is not. I know. Okay,
but when I got off the plane yesterday,
Deion Sanders was right there.
Really hadn't been on the phone
standing next to whom I believe was
his daughter. I would have totally,
I did throw it like a sub prime
and he was,
he was in the middle of a conversation
on his phone, so I knew like, no,
don't like, it's like, hey man. But he
was like talking to some, I go sub prime,
I stuck out my hand. But he was like,
yeah. So he's like, all right man.
So I capital kept talking. Yeah.
That's cool. That's cool. That's good.
Deanna is,
it's not a line of people trying to excel.
You started selfie rumble.
I wouldn't do that to Neon Dionne.
That's beautiful. What is this
thing that you do on your podcast,
which is a hilarious podcast too.
I really enjoyed the all,
we had those a lot of the best time with
you. We had a great time. It was fun.
It's called your mom's house and you
guys, you do it. You have live shows,
which I still have to see because I keep
hearing amazing things about him a lot.
I get a lot of Twitter messages for
people that are senior live shows.
It's so far we're doing it this, this
Sunday in San Francisco at cops. Oh Shit.
Shit. Um, you guys have a bunch
of games that you play? Yeah,
we play segments. One of them was
black or Tom. Yeah. Tom Or blind. Yes.
Tom Or black where you imitate
black people and then you know,
actual recordings of black
people talking. Yes. And I,
did anybody ever call you racist for that?
Sure.
What's the argument?
What do they say?
They say black people don't
really talk like that.
It's really some black people don't
really know to be honest with you. It's,
it's very minimal. It's not, not a lot
of people say that I think because,
well I think that like,
I think people really know intent.
I think people really gauge.
Oh, that's hilarious. You
Online, do you read Twitter?
Well, no, I'm saying like as far
as like a listener of our show,
I don't think that they go,
you're being super racist.
I think that they like to me for,
for doing the game and
doing like a black voice,
but it's not the listeners of your
show that you have to worry about.
It's people find out about your show.
You're not listening to then think it's
cute to ride a salon.com article about
everything that's wrong with podcasting.
Your Mom's house races, races, phobic,
you know, Fart worshiping.
Yeah. I mean, on my special,
my special has,
I don't do the game,
but I basically have a bit
that's kind of in line with that.
Talk about shouting black as black
people and trying to trick them. So,
and how I did it to big daddy came one
time. So like I have a bit about that.
And of course, like if you go at, you read
some of the reviews, people were like,
this was super racist, this guy
did that. I think they're silly.
I think they're nonsense. I think. I think
most people get that. Like, you know,
that bit came out of like, it's, it's,
it's really out of like love. It's
out of like total, uh, from, from,
from my point of view, like
adoration of, uh, black daddy cake,
Daddy Kane, black culture.
Absolutely. So that's true. You,
you're a big rap fan I think. I think
people pick up on that. I think they do.
So anybody who knows you
knows you're not a racist.
Anybody listens to your podcast, knows
that you love to be silly. Of course,
that's a silly show. You and your wife
are both ridiculously silly and your show,
it's at all a comic couples that I know
you guys are without a doubt the best,
but also the best together.
Like you're not just funny people that
happened to be married to each other.
Like you guys work off each
other like really well.
We have a really good pair of shoes.
Yeah, you guys are hilarious. It's so fun.
But that black or Tom
or Tom or black thing,
that's one of those things where like
are we pretending that there aren't black
people that talk like that? Like what
are these videos that we're watching?
You watch pimps opposed down who
are these people? Are they actors?
Is this a role? Is this preposterous?
It's insane if you like.
It's one of those things
too where it's like,
I know the person that does that goes
black people don't talk like that. Right?
They'd be like, you're, you're making
a mockery of life. The, and I go,
what my response would be like,
well, you're right that all people,
black people don't talk like that.
But you know,
some black people somewhere do
do a, what's that play? Blah.
Tom Ha, I'm a Holler at you later. That's,
he's a guy who talks like that for sure.
But it's cute that you're not allowed to
do it because of the color of your skin
because of where your parents
were born or whatever.
But a black guy could do the exact
same voice the exact same way.
All white guys are like,
Hey, yeah, Richard Pryor,
you started that off and then how many,
how many black comics did that after that?
But they did it bad was prior.
Prior was much more subtle. My mom, she's
a great old Gal. Right, right, right.
I mean, nobody had really done that back
then when he was doing it, you know? Yeah.
When I did, I did a bit about the
first 48 where like, you know, it's,
I break down the show.
Right.
And how there's some really aggressive
black guys on that show yelling crazy
shit. And I do an impression of it, dude.
I the the biggest response of
like positive flipping out,
holy shit reaction was always in crowds
where there's a lot of black people.
Yeah. Because they're not offended
by it. They're not offended.
They know it's true. Yeah. And if
also someone's secure. Yeah. They're,
they're not going to worry like what
you saying? We're all like that.
What kind of crazy person
says all like that. Of course,
you know everything else you've, you've,
you've saw all this other material.
You laughed at all this sudden you
saw this other insight and you think,
oh but it's all just a trick to get you
to laugh at some racist shit cause I'm a
racist. Yeah. And then,
and I think that black people who really
flipped out and loved that bit we're
doing, cause they were like, yeah,
they've seen the first 48 and they
know exactly what I'm highlighting.
They know what I'm making fun
of. You know, if you were black,
you could do it with no problem.
Absolutely. But if you're white,
you can do white voices.
You can do like no,
no one ever gets mad at
you doing a redneck voice.
100% but black people could do the redneck
voice too. Right? That's different.
That is true. They can mock rednecks
all day long and no one says a peep.
No one cares. No one cares.
Yeah. Anybody can mock rednecks.
Rednecks mock themselves. Yeah. Jeff
Foxworthy. You might be a redneck
if your mama and your daddy live in. Yeah,
of course. Yeah. You might be a redneck,
you know it's mocking rednecks.
Nobody cares. Yeah. Cause he's white.
If your uncle's trousers right in
the yard. But if he was black, yeah.
Still know who care. True.
Like black people are,
they have full license to
make fun of white people and
white culture. Yeah, sure.
I think we all kind of accept that.
Right? I mean like that's, there's,
there's no argument against it because
part of it is because, you know, like the,
the kind of the, the ladder,
the socioeconomic ladder.
So it's like if you're a white male,
you're automatically perceived
as you have it the best.
So like you making, you have to be, it's,
it's about like what you're making fun of.
You can make fun of the other races
where you can make a joke involving race,
but like what's your angle on it?
If you're just like, you know,
fucking these people are just dumb.
Like that's going to be a racist thing
to say. But if you're making a point,
like there's some joke, something
you're specifying, then it's,
I think you can accept the joke.
You know?
Also when it comes to like super
progressive or liberal people,
there's always this,
this mindset you're supposed to punch
up so the minorities punching up at the
white people would always be the correct
thing, right? It's always allowed.
Like perfect example, like
a famous person. Like anyone
can mock a famous person,
but there was a famous person
mocks a regular person.
Like what if Kim Kardashians just went
to some girl's Instagram page and started
shitting on her and making youtube
videos better feet and like,
look how ugly you are. A
bitch. Look, you already baby.
People would freak the fuck out. But you
read this stuff that women write to her.
Yeah. They use their own Facebook profile.
They feel totally free to do this.
They're not worried. Oh my
gosh. Good to the mentions.
The mentions under a
Kim Kardashians tweet.
Any tweet Baru to Instagram.
There was an Instagram
of her with her daughter,
but she had cropped her
daughter's face out.
It was just her holding her daughter and
the fucking hate the people that just
hate it on her.
Lol.
Thank you for giving me another reason
to hate your fucking retarded stupid ass.
Like just saying that evil shit.
Why'd you crop your daughter out?
You fucking skanky bitch and
like all this like crazy.
It would be great by the way, if she
started making videos, making fun of me.
Just find someone focus on one of those
girls who said that one thing can make
and just open up each of
the bat. It just page. Yeah.
Let me pull up into a mansion in
her Bentley and go, come on inside.
I want to show you one of my favorite
people on the Internet and go to this girl
fucking shit on her. It'd
be hilarious. Go crazy.
People that would never defend her in
a million years would go crazy if she
attacked someone on the
Internet. Yeah. She's just
like, Amanda [inaudible]. I'm a,
I'm going to make a special video
just about you. You stupid bitch.
And then just laid her, oh my God. Public
support. But she's supposed to eat it.
She's supposed to eat it and say nothing
because she's famous and she's above.
She's like thought to be privileged.
Do you respond?
Do you have any reaction to
any more? It's a hatred. Ah,
it's not worth it most of the time. Yeah.
I just block them. Just block them, take,
ignore them or block them depending on
how egregious it is. If it's just super,
like sometimes you go to someone's Twitter
page and it's like all they've been
doing for the last, Haier is hating on
you and you didn't even know it until now.
And I almost feel like I have this feeling
where like part of me goes, you know,
I think they want the block. That's
all I can say. They could be,
I got black so I don't,
I go just no response is the best.
Like you don't even have,
but then they'll interact with
you again like you could, I get,
but if you don't respond at all,
it's just a one way interaction.
That's what it is most of
the time. Yeah. I, but I,
I definitely don't
respond if I do respond,
if by like someone might
think something incorrectly,
like the married be upset
at me for something and it's
like maybe they got wrong.
Like maybe I'll respond if I feel
like if I'm going to get correct,
but if they're shitty insulting,
like why would I bother you
choose who you communicate with.
I'm not shitting and insulting, you
know, if you come out of the gate,
like me personally, like I, if I, even if
I say something that you disagree with,
if you just start insulting
me like right off the bat,
well we're not communicating
because I don't even know you.
Like you might have a point, I might
listen to that point if you weren't a cut,
but if you just come right at
me with that, like why bother?
There's plenty of people in this world.
It's game over. There's a lot of people.
There's no need to like there's,
there's great criticism that you can
get from people that are thinking
thoughtful people and it
helps you form opinions.
There's a lot of smart people that
you don't know. You haven't met them.
They have a different point of view.
It's great.
It's one of the beautiful
things about the internet,
but the cons just don't bother. There's
not enough time. Not enough time. I agree.
I just can't. But that's something
you learn. You know, you learn from,
like I had this Guy John
Wayne par on the other day.
He's multiple time world boy Thai
champion, like super tough guy.
You would think this is the
kind of guy doesn't give a fuck.
He's like texting me. He's like, God,
these fucking assholes on Twitter and
youtube. I'm like, it's funny, I just,
people being mean talking shit about him.
Well somebody like that, probably the,
it's like as a comedian
you're used to rejection more.
And especially with the way
that social media developed,
you know like Youtube and Netflix,
there's,
there's a forum for people
to go, like you suck, right?
So after a while when you
see those they don't like,
they don't affect you as much.
You know, you build up a little,
a bit of a tolerance to it,
but I bet somebody that comes on your
show that maybe is accomplished and well
known,
but maybe it doesn't have a big social
media presence when they first get those,
you're the fucking dumbest person ever.
We'd be texting her like, what the fuck?
You know, the biggest one was
uh, well he was a pretty big,
John is a big one because first of all,
John Wayne Park,
although he's a multiple time world
Moitai champion, he's a really sweet guy.
Super Nice and he would
never be like that.
He would never like think of
like insulting someone like that.
Someone does it to him and he's like,
wow, what's going on? Yeah. Fuck.
Well was coming from, but
they, you know, they don't,
they don't get that experience that,
that weird public guy experience that
you get when you hit him with 1.5 million
Twitter followers. Like you tweet some
something like that and like they're like,
they feel that wave of people
and a certain amount of
them are just going to be
shitheads. Sure, sure. If you
have 100,000 people view a tweet,
which is very possible when you
got 1.5 million Twitter followers,
100,000 people looking at a tweet,
man,
you're going to get a few hundred
complete fuckheads. Yeah. You just gonna.
It's just like you pull a net, you're
going to get a certain type of fish.
You know,
if you a net across a mile of ocean,
you're going to get a cross section
of all the fish that are in the ocean.
Maybe a few dozen in that area.
You're going to get assholes.
Yeah, true, true, true.
But just don't interact with them.
It was like there's no point.
And if you're that person,
if you're a person who's just lashing
out at someone like that and insulting,
unless it's funny, some people are
pretty funny. Yeah. If they're funny,
they get a pass. If you're
funding, you get a pass.
But if you're just doing it to be funny,
if you're doing, if you're just rage,
like you always know that it's never
about what they're screaming about or
something that was going
on in that person's life to
to put that kind of energy
into just spewing venom at
people, you know? Well it's
an effective, first of all,
it might be effect.
You might think it's effective.
You see someone on a top of a pedestal.
I Kim Kardashians and like that fucking
bitch and her Gucci underwear and you
want to attack her. But she's
still her. Yeah, she's still her.
You're still you and all that energy
you spent hating on someone who doesn't
even know you're alive and could have
been spent on improving your own life.
Right. And do you feel you don't
feel better, you'd never feel better.
You don't could feel better if it
was funny though, if it was funny,
but if you're just just like,
I fucking hate you bitch.
You still be kind of like
all that stuff is like,
oh well it's just people that don't
understand what's going on and one day all
that shit is going to come out.
Like there's gonna come a point in time
where you're not gonna be able to do
that.
It's not going to be as easy as just like
attacking someone anonymously or it's
like you're going to be exposed for like
the stuff that you're running or who
you are, what your presence is. You know,
the weird thing is like kids today,
they're also going to be
responsible for things. You know?
Like maybe if a kid today is 21 and they
got some crazy Instagram page and then
going fucking buck wild and then one
day they're 27 28 and they have a
respectable job and they've got their
shit together and they've moved on with
their life about this out fucking
Internet, man, these it hadn't.
Pictures are still out. It happens now.
Why do you have underwear on your head?
Yeah. You're going to be the CEO of this
company. You've got a picture with you.
You're drunk.
If underwear over your head,
it's your friend blowing you or is he
pretending to blow you pretending to blow
it? The photos are less of an
issue for people than the comments.
Like if you write some
shit, I mean shit. Oh yeah.
There's been cops that like have a,
you know,
they have their online alias and then
somebody finds out and they're like,
look what this guy has been commenting on
things and then that's it. You're done.
Did you see the guy who has zero zero
criminal record and he's facing a
potential life imprisonment for
flashing gang signs on social media?
Pull that up Jim. Oh yeah,
it is fucking bizarre.
Like 2015 in America,
there was a guy with no criminal record.
Nothing. He hasn't done anything.
They arrest him for
throwing gang signs up.
What did they say that he's
affiliated with south? Uh,
I feel like that's like of this San Diego
man with no criminal record faces life
in prison for flashing
gang signs on Facebook.
How old is this gentleman? First of all,
let's, let's look at that right there.
Harvey and the rapper.
His name is Aaron Harvey and
14 other men including rapper,
tiny do were charged under an obscure
California law accusing them of conspiring
with gang members who shot nine
people in 2013 to early 2014.
What the fuck?
Find out how old that gentleman is.
I mean, you're hanging out with your
friends and they're throwing gang signs.
You don't want to get beat up.
You might throw a gang sign up to for it.
That's completely ridiculous,
man. What is the video down there?
What does that say?
Let's hear what he says.
How could we stop?
Um,
me and my family have been
living in the southeast
since the mid field.
Um,
I've had most of the jobs,
no criminal record.
Both the police continues to be spotless
weather and it's not specifically on
driving. I understand you guys
have the number though. Driving.
The majority of stops happen
when people are either a,
her parent's house or a
friend's house or wall walk.
So I believe I've been stopped just
off the top of my head since I was 14.
I'm 26 now. 50 something times that's
Korean. I do not have a criminal record.
I believe only one citation
was ever given you. He said,
I did turn on my blinker
within a hundred feet. Turn
one of these stuffs, uh, was in
front of my grandmother's house.
Police officers driving by any waves.
I waved back not doing anything.
I'm on my property. He pulls up
immediately. I'm putting handcuffs.
I don't know why I'm asking
you why. You know, why?
Why are you guys with my property?
He tells me if the middlemen come
on your property without permission.
So can we.
They go in my wallet.
They find that I'm a trained
emergency medical technician.
The sergeant tells me,
Oh wow, no you, you,
you're working to close to us.
We're going to have to do
something about this. Immediately.
I knew to stay in Las Vegas,
I mean fear and our communities living
in fear of the police because of these
things. And because of these numerous
stops of no crime has been committed,
just mirror stops of being in front of
my grandma's house, my parents' house,
or just hanging out.
And police have falsely
documented as a gang member.
And because I'm documented as a gang
because San Diego police department,
now I'm a liable or eligible
of this proposition.
Law Is in 21 penal code one a 2.5 and
right now I'm facing life in prison
with no knowledge of these crimes
being committed or anything.
So I believe that the problem is it,
is it the profile and when
you're pulled over while driving,
the police will say, well, why
am I being pulled over? Well,
I'll tell you when to me,
but get out the car.
Well,
there you go.
I think I believed him and I think you
need to use his voice for Tom or black.
She thinks it would be a good one for you.
Wow. Did you, did you see, there it goes.
All my black jokes now. Thanks for
depressing us. Um, did you see the,
the Department of Justice Report on
Ferguson? Well, where they say, oh dude,
you got to see this really pull it up
after the Michael Brown shooting and you
know, there was no indictment of police
officer Darren Wilson, the, you know, um,
attorney general went down and said,
we're going to investigate what
happens going to take a little while.
So they really,
they have a department of Justice
investigated and they found just so much
racism in that department. Like
the stats are alarming. It's like,
you know, 67% of the population
is black, but like arrests,
88% of the time are black. Um, and
the comparison to the white stats,
it's, it's, it's a statistically,
it's one of the most damning
reports you'll ever see.
Does it take into account white
people just being awesome? It doesn't,
but I like smiles. It takes him
to how awesome our smiles are.
But there's less contrast with our teeth
or they're not as dramatic. It's, yeah,
exactly. We don't get enough credit
for our smiles and all right. Uh,
dude. Like how, how often, um,
black people who were arrested,
they were going to look at this report,
detailed out Ferguson operated
at a vertically integrated
system from street cop
to court clerk to judge to
city administrator to city
council to raise revenue
for the city budget through increased
ticketing and finding, whoa.
But the dude, the stats are the
craziest, like, um, like all,
all the fucking arrests, uh, or black
people were at a such a disproportionate,
you know, disadvantage. Um,
as far as like how often they were
arrested when they were not doing anything
and like,
no contraband walking down the street.
Like that guy said versus like,
um, the white a white person was,
it's not even comparable really.
Uh, how often force was used, like,
you know, 10 to one black to white. Like
it's crazy stats every time a, um, uh,
uh,
a dog has bitten a person in Ferguson
and since the report was put together all
at 100% black, like all, all that,
it's, it's just so blatant. It's,
it's to be fair that the whole town
is pretty much black though. Well,
I think they said it was 67%.
Right? Um, well there's, there's
a good a New York Post, uh,
a report on it where they pretty
much went through it and, uh,
pretty much that that's why this is
this not as racist as you think. Well,
you know what? Quit crying then. I,
I mean, I'm sure it is, but, well, we've
talked about this a hundred times before.
If you're in a bad neighborhood,
you grew up in a bad neighborhood,
you have families that had
been involved in crime. It's a,
it's a system that you're
stuck in your story,
whether it's some sort
of grand conspiracy,
which some people claim or just some
inescapable sort of momentous thing where
you've got momentum on your side
or against you rather, you know,
momentum of your, your family, your
neighborhood, the kids you grew up with,
all these people involved in crime,
that momentum is very,
very difficult to break.
It's very difficult to get a fresh start.
So thinking that anyone who grows up in
those environments should have to behave
exactly the same way without
any consideration for how
they've been developed
and grown up in comparison to a guy
like Tommy bonds who had it light.
I'm walking around in Florida would
fucking shorts on what I'm saying.
Sandals too. Did you, uh,
sometimes what those feet fly,
do you want to hear some of these stats?
Sure. They're pretty crazy. All right.
Despite making up 67% of the population,
African Americans accounted
for 85% of traffic stops.
90% of citations.
So that goes back to the money thing.
And 93% of Ferguson Police
Department rests from 2012 to 2014.
That's what I mean.
I occasionally arrest a white person
just for goof of African Americans,
2.7 times 2.07 times more likely to
be searched during a vehicular stop,
but our 26% less likely to
have contraband found on them.
Look at this.
The statistics don't prove racism because
blacks don't commit traffic offenses
at the same rate as
other population groups.
It's pretty instant what
they're trying to say.
That's a really nice way of saying
black people caused more crime.
That's what they're saying,
but they're saying it doesn't prove racism
because black people just caused more
crime.
That's what they're saying.
Blacks were 31% more likely than whites
to be pulled over for a traffic stop
nationwide. Nationwide, it's pretty, uh,
so first and being a
black majority of town,
if it's blacks are pulled over the
same rate as blacks nationally,
that account for 87.5% of
the traffic stops this,
so it's racist even by that standard.
This one's pretty a amazing African
Americans account for 95% of manner of
walking charges, manner
of walking. Hold on.
There's a manner of walking charge.
94% of all fail to comply charges.
92% of resisting arrest,
92% of peace disturbance
and 89% of failure to obey.
What about pimp Strutton?
99.9% really a law.
You're not allowed to walk a certain way,
man of minor of walking.
I think that's like falls into like that
Jay walking stuff like, oh, that's like,
come on man. Manner of walking in your
calling, something manner of walking.
I don't like the way you lean to the left.
How about you?
Be a little more fucking specific manner
of walking charges. That's pretty crazy.
Jamie.
Google manner of walking charges.
Tell us what manner of
walking charges and tail.
Even jaywalking is fucking goofy.
They bag people in Hollywood for Jay
walking all the time. I've seen it. Yeah.
People Cross sunset.
They're trying to keep people from dying.
All this texting assholes
out here. They're already
going up on sidewalks there.
Yeah, they could just,
you know what they can do?
They could just send sugar around and
make sure people don't Jaywalk and I don't
think he's around right now.
I think he's busy in jail.
He was pretty big after that video.
He's pretty fucked though, right?
Wouldn't you assume?
Yeah. That's pretty bad.
But maybe not if they could
prove that guy had a gun. Yeah.
It'd be funny if they pull the, um,
uh, the gap, one of the gas pedals.
There's a thing.
I don't think you were saying that and
he said he really didn't know that he was
very fortunate. He says in fear of his
life, right? Yeah. He might've been. Yeah.
I don't, I don't, I don't
know, man. I think that's,
that's probably gonna now if Robert
Durst had been driving that truck,
that'd be something innocuous.
Municipal Principal Code Municipal Code
requires pedestrians to walk on the
sidewalks or close to the side
of the road whenever possible.
It's intent is to make sure
people don't block a road.
But according to a federal port,
police have routinely used the law for
another purpose too fine and harassed.
Blacks. I don't like how they wrote
blacks. How about black people? I can't,
they're not black.
They're black people.
African Americans accounted for 95% of
manner of walking among along roadway
charges from 2011 to 2013 95% wow.
And that's nationwide.
Converses Fergus, Fergus,
they called it walking
black walking black.
You would leave out of your house to go
to the store and you might not make it
back. Wow. Wow. Fucked up place.
They stalk you and stop you. He said,
they will say, Hey, what's your name?
Got Any warrants. Why he's strolling
through the neighborhood. Come here.
You look suspicious. What
the fuck man. See that.
That is just crazy that they and that
they actually somehow or another that
fuels the system and that by finding
people and arresting people and all that,
it's somehow another fuels the system.
That's slavery.
I mean that's the Lee really is
a style of slavery. These stats.
I mean I think they'd probably have to
feel black people in Ferguson probably
just feel it feel really validated after,
after all the marching and then people and
being like, and people, cause you know,
people were like, come on, this is, we're
just whining. This is not whining. No,
94% of all failure to comply
charges were filed against blacks.
The whole thing of walking down the
road and people pull up and start asking
questions like that, unless you're doing
something wrong, leave me the fuck alone.
Of course, that's what America's all
about. That we do get left alone. Yeah,
we do get left on and
that's what it should
be. Right. That happened to
me the other day though. I
kind of look at you dude.
What happened?
Agon you sag at least just made like
came on like I was getting out of my car
and uh, pops like, what are
you doing man? I'm like, uh,
getting into going into my house,
had my book bag and he goes,
let me see your id and like,
why are you on at my house right now?
And he made me like show him and his
license and stuff and, and it was all my,
he was just like, you just look
weird man. You have a book bag.
You're going into your house,
you're not two in the morning.
And then I filmed the whole thing.
I just took out my phone and just go,
why are you, why are you at making
it? This is like months ago. It's, no,
it's at home.
I could find it for you.
I just don't want to start a
fight with the Glendale birdies.
Ari and I have to ask you,
is it okay if I upload the video of you
two arguing about American sniper? Yeah,
of course. Of course. I just had, I don't
want to be rude. Oh, that's nice of you.
I don't get it for you,
but not good for Ari.
America is going to be very upset at
his lack of patriotism and his, look,
let's just put it this way because
here's the truth.
Shrew fest has side effects.
Good Ole Ari.
I'll do my impression of art.
Those are going to war.
They're like my favorite.
Let's go to war. What are you talking
about? And then he goes, uh, yeah,
like he goes, yeah, Bradley Cooper did
like a good impression of of the guy.
And I'm like, well that's the fucking
Gig asshole. Like if you're an actor,
it's like, can you do a good
impression? And like he's like
getting shot was actually a good choice.
17 minutes movie.
He was killed that day in writing.
Listen, you communists fuck
duty. They show his whole training, 40
minute training. Same thing for no reason.
Straining for fucking 40 minutes.
No reason to training because you're
seeing how hard it is to become a seal.
You mean? No reason. That's a different
story. It's a different story.
It's his story. It's a character
study. You didn't, you didn't think it.
We didn't feel it at all.
There was not a moment where I was
like lost and it was like, wow,
you're really feel on top of being back
home now. All contrived. You see him,
he has PTSD. He was defending
me. It's actually resigned. Yeah,
because you have a black eye.
Of course.
It was so fun to be there that
night that you think that night.
Yeah. That night, by the way,
I that was you miss pat.
Ms Pat was hand,
but she was hanging Joe on stage.
Joe [inaudible],
Ari and myself. That was one of the most
fun lineups I've ever been a part of.
It was murderous. That was pretty,
pretty murderous. That was worn
to the ground. By the time when
the people left out of there,
they were like wiping your forehead
25 minutes set so longer. It wasn't,
everybody did 25 minutes. Pretty crazy
show. Yeah, it was chaos, man. They,
they're beautiful.
Place is the best. And we're on
Ari show, uh, this Thursday night.
It's Thursday and I are in the same
episode. Christella Alonzo. Um,
we each tell a a story on our Recia fears.
This is not happening.
12:30 AM Thursday night.
Don't like look for it.
Wednesday at 12:30 AM don't be an asshole.
You know what I'm talking about?
You're up on Thursday. You stay
at your out clause. 12:30 AM
you should shut the fuck up and
understand how America works. Fun.
12:30 AM I'm awake, bitch. It's
four o'clock in the morning.
It's not four o'clock in the morning. The
next day, four o'clock in the morning,
Saturday night. You know why it's Saturday
night? Cause I'm still out. I'm out.
I'm out. This is fucking Saturday night
midday for me buddy. Yeah, that's a,
that's a Thursday night.
I don't know if I,
I haven't seen it.
So I'm excited to see whether I
did that taping for this episode.
The day I got back from
Hong Kong or like the night.
So I am on like I fell asleep in
the green room. They're sitting up
and somebody was like, hey man. And
I stood up and I started to, to like,
I was so jet lagged crazy, but I still
had a blast. It was, you know, it was,
those crowds are amazing.
Yeah. And his new special,
which is not as new specialist
that she was last special, uh,
heirs this Friday night too. Um, that's
uh, that's what's that one called?
That's called a passive aggressive,
passive aggressive. Yeah.
Passive aggressive airs. Friday you
could still get his other special,
which is fucking awesome,
which is called paid regular,
which you could get that one on comedy
central direct. And you could also,
it airs occasionally. You know, they
replay those things sometimes. So, uh,
check your local listings.
You fucks. Yeah. Fuck faces.
Ari's balling out of control. I had them
on yesterday. He's so confident now.
It's hilarious. It's great. Huh?
He's a different guy. It's so weird.
I was going up that hill where a
pink.is and he isn't that billboard.
That's right.
If it,
but like I was in traffic and I'm just
like looking up and it's suddenly see
just Ari's eyes poke up from the,
uh,
the hill when you're driving up that
hill because the billboard. Yeah,
just see Ariz face on crazy. So
he's super confident now, Huh?
He's balling out of control.
He was on a podcast yesterday shitting
on Howard stern telling him and Clint
Eastwood go suck. They're old, old
man. Dick Stuck. Shut her off hard.
Just did it again. He just bashes
podcasts. Look on those every episode now.
Podcasts when I was six years
old and I was like, yeah,
it's called you had a tape recorder,
Howard, chill the fuck out. Well, why?
As I said to,
I don't have any problem with them saying
that because it doesn't make any sense
and I feel like he's baiting
people to talk about his was his
thing is play that
people didn't know when,
how he dominated radio was that
when he was introduced to a market,
the first thing he did was shit.
The number one local show.
Like he would shit on that show and
then that the people that listen to that
show would find out,
they would end up checking out his show.
He Baits people this way. He, I think
every, almost everything he does is calc.
What's that?
Do you think this though?
Is that or do you think this
is just having an old man,
but I think you can say that part of it.
I think it's part of it may.
He's genuinely, he's like, that's stupid.
The other part is he knows that podcasts
are getting big, make fun of podcasts,
make them come listen to the show. He,
it's not like the guy's a brilliant,
that's what I've been saying.
Give me some knuckles dog a bit.
I'll like fucking American sniper
where I see it too. For sure.
You're not going to like that
movie? No. Why? I haven't seen it,
but everyone tells me it's
like the shittiest movie ever.
You're like the first
person about everyone.
I've talked to quite a
few people that liked it.
It's not the shittiest movie ever. I don't
understand like what should go see it.
If you seen it, I will still go see
it together. I can see it together.
I see it together. We'll make
a report. Okay. It's you know,
equal c together before and
we'll do a podcast at night.
We'll see it in there during the day
and we'll come in. Definitely can see,
you know, people saying I like to
move at all for any movie. Right.
I liked that movie. I don't
want that movie. Sure. Like
that. It's a piece of shit,
not a fucking chance. If you think it's
a piece of shit, you're fucking retarded.
Like that's something is wrong with
you. If you go, that's a piece of shit,
garbage movie. It's, it's ridiculous.
It's sick, man. It's a quality film.
I didn't see it. It's a quality,
uh, snipers up quality for,
I could see you not liking different
things about it. You can be like,
I'm against war, I'm against, you know,
military, all that stuff. Absolutely.
But to be, and you can even say like,
I don't like it, but to be like,
that's a piece of garbage movie.
It's ridiculous.
What do you think was
better that a lone survivor?
I didn't see either one of them.
I think lone survivor was pretty fucking
fantastically done as far as the wars
and battles. Yeah. Though that,
which is basically the whole film.
It's a really good movie.
And that surprised the shit
out of me. I saw it at home.
I, you know, the billboard and
never did anything. I was like,
I don't want to see this.
I thought,
I thought lone survivor was one of
those like fucking Rambo movies.
When I saw the, I thought lone
survivor, like one against everybody,
like that kind of shit. Just a
fiction. That's what I thought I did.
I didn't look into it and it came on
when I just started and I was like,
it's fucking midnight. I'll
watch this. It's really good.
It's going to be real hard for someone
to make a fictional movie that really
resonates about war other than
like a hurt locker type move.
Right.
Where you show like some weird aberration,
like the student wants to keep going
back and yeah. And uncork bombs. So May,
I mean, my argument with art,
which you'll see it like,
we argue too about like how Cooper did
as far as portraying the role now that I
think he did a great job.
I mean I thought there's a lot of layers
to his performance and you see somebody
suffer from PTSD in the film as
effectively as you could show it.
I thought he did a great job. Um, did
you like zero dark 30? Yeah, I like that.
I'd like to,
but I didn't like is the bullshit.
There's one likes that fact that they
had created this woman who are, you know,
was the architect of this thing. And then
I found out that she exist. I went why?
I thought that she did exist. It's
just not what I heard. Really? Yeah.
That the woman that like was gone to the,
to the Messenger.
I heard that that was a uh, a plump
piece. Pull that up. Jamie. Makes sure,
I'm sure I'm correct because
I'm getting it from a ranting.
I'm a army ranger who had a few
beers in him. Oh really? Yeah.
We just all bullshit. He was explaining
to me what was bullshit about it.
I was bullshit that they would
never listen to her like this.
This whole thing is ridiculous.
Like the way they portrayed
everybody was ridiculous.
Then there's the story
which is very different.
The story that the guy
wrote that was there,
the guy who apparently was
there on the raid who wrote,
which differs from other peoples
versions of the event. Yeah.
Makes you wonder, man, I wonder
how much of these guys, you know,
cause the Chris Kyle thing had come under
fire from a lot of people because he
apparently lied about a lot of
shade up some shit for sure.
Made up a lot of shit in his book and
you've got to wonder how much these guys
are involved in this insanely
risky endeavor. Right?
You're,
you're fucking special ops soldier.
You're out there doing nothing shit in
the middle of the night with night vision,
shooting people, fucking high,
high, high risk. And you know, they,
when they realize like this is
not going to pay off financially,
the only way to do it. It's just fucking
listen, let's juice this story up. Yeah,
let's add some stuff to this.
Let's throw some,
some controversial shit in there that's
going to guarantee that people are going
to talk about it. True. You know? Yeah. I
mean, and like, you know, I, I've, I've,
I've saw, I've read the articles about
like things that he claimed and there's,
I don't know if there's a real
woman. Yeah. So it is a real woman.
That's what said he was
talking crazy. Say what? Okay,
let's find out what wasn't
true about zero, dark 30.
What was incorrect about
zero, dark 30. Cause, um,
that's a big,
a big thing about me lately is he's
fucking movies that are unreal life and
they, they make shit up. Yeah. Um,
because of that, a Fox catcher
movie, which, uh, was about this guy,
Mark Schultz who fought in the UFC and uh,
all sorts of bullshit and
then moving and he's actually,
he made a Twitter post about it yesterday,
uh,
asking people if they were interested
in him giving a detailed account of all
the inaccuracy. So the movie, he
said, if people are interested in it,
let me know and I'll do that.
And so people serve responding to him.
And I retweeted it cause I
want to know all the different,
cause I know a bunch of them. Yeah.
Just based on who he was at the time,
like that he was already a world champion,
that it was already one of the best
wrestlers on the planet. That he was, uh,
the UFC wasn't even around when they had
him watching the UFC in 1987. It didn't,
didn't exist. All this weird gay shit
between him and that dupont, not real,
no one says that like they made a bunch
of shit up to try to move the story
along and it's about, a guy's really
lost. I do this every movie though,
every movie that has a, that's
based on, you know, a real story,
there's added characters, added moments
to dramatize the added stuff to, to,
you know, peak your interest in and make
the story more interesting. And yeah,
it's, it's kind of a, they should
almost at the end of films put up, uh,
like a slate
that just shows you everything.
Like here are the scenes that
we completely had it made
up. You know what I mean?
So you would walk away
going, oh, okay. Yeah.
Well apparently there's a lot of
people that think that zero dark,
dirty has, there's a lot of
shit in it. That's bullshit.
Well, there's a whole, uh,
I'm,
I'm looking at several articles about
the factual errors or the things that he
just made, made, made up about
zero, dark 30 apparently. I mean,
and obviously this guy is not going to
come clean about what's accurate and not,
but um, it was a CIA
director at the time. Uh,
he's played by Gandel
Feeney in zero, dark 30. Um,
I can't remember what her name,
whatever. Um, but he said that like,
cause I think Daniel Fini
curses in the movie as him.
And I'm like, when he's playing
the part of this guy and he goes,
that's the only accurate part of
that movie. I say, fuck a lot.
Yeah.
Well they don't,
they're not really that interested in
making things accurate when they can,
they're,
they're interested in making things
accurate and not accurate enough and then
good. Yeah. And that's where these,
that's why I think it's like,
to dramatize the true story,
you have a massive obligation.
You have a massive obligation
to make it interesting,
but also to make it factual
because it's a true story.
A lot of people find out about certain
things and they hear about them from a
movie you expect like, Oh, it's
based on a true story. You know,
that really this guy really did this. And
then you find out, nope, never did that.
Like the Reuben Carter hurricane movie,
you know that movie? Yes. A dead zone.
Winfrey had the guy on the show and wow,
we let them loose and it's, you know,
the guy was in jail and it was all wrong.
It was against him and he could
have been the champion of the world.
And then there's a cop in the movie.
It's always trying to get him,
the cop wasn't even real.
The cop didn't exist.
Like this one cop that's been trying
to try to get him his whole life.
So you made a story about a
real guy and his real story,
but then you added this
character in there,
sort of move everything along the way.
You think it should in a good guy,
bad guy movie. But I see, you know,
in my limited experience with this,
like I have a, a script thing that I'm
working on and like when I, Oh shit,
when I get me Buns, when I get
the notice screenwriting. Yeah.
When you get notes from like producers
or network people, you're like,
it's always stuff like
add something like this,
but that this character should
have more of somebody that,
that challenges them this way. And
so you see like, I see how you go,
but isn't the meat of this like,
doesn't this work enough as a story?
And it's like, yeah, but
you know, this is what we,
this is how we make stories is
how movies and shows are made.
So add all these elements to it.
You got to have autonomy if you're
going to have your own creation. I mean,
cause that's the problem
with movies and TV shows.
They cost a lot of money to make it so
when a lot of people were putting their
money up,
they want results and they want it to
be their way and they want to get there,
a little greasy fingers all over,
which is why you have to listen to their,
their opinions.
Otherwise you'd be like,
imagine if that was the case with standup.
I'm actually,
if you became an entity as a
standup comedian, like, Hey Tom, uh,
we really like what you're
doing out there, so we want
to be in business with Ya.
So what we're gonna do is,
uh,
we're going to put up the money
for all your travel or your hotel,
going to give you a salary and we're
going to be a part of Thompson or
enterprises and we're going
to have meetings every week
and what are we working
on this week? Well, here's the script
that Bobby and the writers have come up.
You know,
you can alter this if you like Tom,
as long as of course we approve it at
the end before you go onstage and you get
to this, like what, what have
I done? We're so spoiled.
That's why it's the last and best thing
that you can never give up if you're
doing it. Yeah, you can't
give it up. We're so spoiled.
So you really get to do whatever you want.
And even more so now
because you have podcasts,
like I've seen how the podcast
has changed your whole thing, man.
You guys sell out everywhere now
you have like a real following.
Did I just did a tour? Like have one
nighters? Almost everyone was sold out.
I mean from uh, Hattiesburg,
Mississippi, which was unbelievable.
This place hubs, city comedy,
Lafayette the next night.
Then I did punchline in Atlanta,
Jacksonville, West Palm Beach Ban.
Almost every show sold out. Yeah.
And it's all podcast fans, podcasts,
podcasts and Netflix, the two of them
together. And it's amazing. Yeah. Yeah.
And this saw internet stuff, all of
it. My whole thing is internet. Yeah.
Isn't that amazing? Yeah.
It's amazing. It's so what,
this is a weird time for that.
Yeah. That's pretty cool, man.
It's so cool because like all the
shit that you have to deal with,
if you're creating a script and it has
to get passed by all these producers and
executives, none of that exists,
but yet all this success exists.
All these people love what you're doing.
Like what fucking studio executive
was sign off on black or Tom,
I don't think nine zero couldn't
have people in the room with you.
They would be like shaking their head,
looking at each other,
I'll talk to them and they would
go Tom. So, hey, um, when, well,
when, well, Tom are black, um, you know,
I just for what you get out of it,
I don't think it's your best
work for what you get out of it.
I just think it's not worth
what you, you know, what you
give up. Sure. Yeah. I mean,
I'm gonna show you some tweets and
the people that think, look at the,
the guy with the egg next to his name,
his name is zero dark 30 thinks you're
a racist. Yeah, we should stop. The,
there was like, I was on a morning news
show, you know, there's like good morning,
whatever things,
and I had on like a black
jacket and a black and gray,
I think either la hat or I think it was
an la hat. It was black and gray. And uh,
he was like big dodger fan.
And I go, no, I hate baseball.
And he was like, ah, okay.
And I go, I just, I just wear hats for
the colors, like black guys, you know,
just to match. And he was
like, Hey, like immediately it
was like, well, we'll, we'll,
we'll work on the areas on
the air. Yeah. I go, you know,
it's just like for you just wear it for
the style, like just for the colors,
like black guys. And he's like, okay,
so this weekend you're going to be at
the like, and he like, I was like, wow.
Like he flipped out and what was his job?
Yeah, immediately. And they're gonna,
he's a news. I'm the comedian.
I could say whatever I want.
But that for him was like, oh, super
risky. Imagine if he said that, hey,
I just wear hats like black
guys. And people would want
his head. Yeah, you can't,
you can't do that. If you're a newscaster
guy, they will have you fucking, yeah.
And he thought afterwards, he was like,
well, you're kind of unpredictable, Huh?
But you, I was like, well, it's not
really that crazy in the world though.
You're a little bitch. You have to
be a company bitch. In that world.
You can't have opinions about anything.
Everything has to be broad and like, yeah,
well we certainly support our
heroes. We'll be right back. Yeah.
Like it has to be like there
can't be any, any, any weird.
There's a weirdness a little
earlier today we had a guest on a,
he made a comment then we just like
everybody to know that uh, we did.
That does not reflect case Sun for news.
Yeah.
Anyone can wear hats of any
color and it's certainly,
I don't even know where he was going
with that. I didn't understand it either.
Anyway, moving on. Some people
were just not that talented.
They have to resort to shock value.
Shock. Carrot top is also going to be,
there's always gonna be people like that.
Unbelievable.
There's no getting around that.
There's always going to be,
those jobs are like you. Like if you're
going to be the guy on the local news,
like you almost have to have zero
flavor. Yeah. You can't have any flavor.
Flavor's bad flavors.
Dangerous gets people sued.
That's with morning radio djs too.
Right? Those guys are dying off.
There's not a whole
lot of those guys left.
That's what's the most funny thing about
Howard saying that podcasting is for
losers and you know,
it's just that the radio job,
which just started happening now and I,
and I knew this was going to
happen and it's finally happening,
is that like they are now
finally clubs are going,
there's no more radio like they're,
they're saying like you go,
so we you to impress my morning.
They're like, we don't do that anymore.
And it'll be like, it's not that like,
oh all you're completely sold out.
We don't have to do any press. They're
just like, it's a waste of time.
They finally realized in, in now that
saying all radios a waste of time,
but they realize in certain markets with
certain shows, they're like, there's not,
we're not going to pay
any more for things.
There's no point in bringing you there.
It doesn't turn into anything.
You don't have to do it.
Well,
there was one radio station where I did
way back in the day when I used to have
to do those morning shows where they,
they talked about how they had a deal
with this radio station where they would
buy ads and because they would buy ads,
the djs would,
it was like a bribe to get the comics
to come in and do the morning show.
So the comics would come
in and do the morning show,
tell them when they were there and they
would buy ads for the radio show during
the day. Wow. I was like, well,
you have to buy ads. Yeah.
You can't get anybody in unless you buy
ads. Like wow. It's that blatant. Blatant.
Yeah. It's great. Now and I've, uh,
there's been like markets now where I go
to and there's radio set up and I'll be
like, I don't want to do it. Okay.
And you know what turnouts like,
great. Like it's not, you know,
the problem with the radio is just getting
up breaks your whole brain up and you
always roll the dice.
There's some great guys doing radio,
but then there's also shows, we
were like, do this. This is a waste.
Why are we doing that? Could get bad.
That's worse than getting up for me.
I think it was like when you
get there and they're like,
what are you going to ask you?
What every once a lie's a slessinger
had some crazy happened recently.
Oh, I think I heard
about that. Yeah. I'll,
I'll let her tell it next
time she was here. But like,
she cracked a joke and she didn't realize
that like this dude's mom was dead.
And uh, the dude like, yeah, kind
of opened the door to begin with.
I don't remember the exact way it went,
but it was a classic example.
It was a classic example.
I could call her and have
her talk about it on the air.
Let's see if she'll do that.
Let's see if she even answers.
Okay.
Give it a shot. I've never
done this before. Fuck it.
But it's just highlighting
how those people can be a
huge pain in the ass. Yeah.
Let's see. You know, patch it in
to the speaker phone.
Yeah, this is how I do, it's
high tech. High Tech is fuck.
Okay.
What does that
sounds like?
What the heck?
That's the government. It's the
government cutting out Joe. Really good.
Stop talking and I say he doesn't need
this. And what does that little weird,
yeah, that would be a
problem. Oh Man. Yeah.
It starts getting text asshole face.
I feel that
the goal of doing standup
long enough and uh, like the,
the biggest mark of success is being
like, oh, I don't have to do radio.
That's the dream. I know. But some
places the dream was to do radio.
Some places it was like to get on the
Bob and Tom Show, you know Bob and Tom,
they fucking said no to Joey Diaz.
He was supposed to go there and someone
saw something on youtube that he did or
most likely everything on youtube.
Yeah.
Anything he's ever seen that's ever
said, ever. Everybody, everything.
I have conversation, they pulled them
off. They pulled them off the show. Yeah.
He sold out every show.
I tweeted the shit out of it.
He sold out every fucking show.
And then Bob and Tom got hit
with a deluge of insults.
You know that you guys are old.
You're fucking idiots. Your losers.
He's the funniest game man. Earth. You
know them up because of a youtube video.
He's not the youtube video. You stupid
fucks. Wow. I don't know what it,
what happened, who's decision
it was to do that. But what's,
so those guys are really good guys too.
I've done the show before and I super,
super nice guys. I don't know whose
decision it was to not have Joey on.
It's just so dumb. That's stupid. He's a
professional. He doesn't swear on the air.
It's not going to do anything stupid. No.
Come on indeed. And might bring in some,
uh, some, some traits for people to try.
Might you might Joe's yeah, he might doze.
Yeah,
you might dose you eat your
breakfast burrito yet. Try this.
Where are you headed to this weekend?
Um, let's see. Tomorrow I'm doing a,
the Ventura Harbor Comedy
Club. Oh, Wednesday night.
And then how was that? That's inventory
California. Yeah. I haven't done far away.
Excited to do it. Yeah, I heard. That's
good. I think it's going to be fun. Um,
Sunday I do the just the podcast live
and then next week, Virginia Beach,
funny bone and I added,
I added a bunch.
I'm doing some big venues
coming up and I added them.
I got a park west in Chicago,
Neptune theater in Seattle.
All of it available. Thomson [inaudible]
dot com very excited. Shit. Yeah.
All right fuckers. Let's wrap this
bitch up. I got to get out of here.
Thanks to do, oh Bob. Brian, you got a
show tomorrow night at the comedy store,
right? Yes. Bert Kreischer are, you should
fear, hurry. Chauffeurs Bam, Bam, Bam,
uh, Ice House tomorrow night
is sold the fuck out. And uh,
that shit's going to be
off the chain as well.
A majestic theater in Dallas Friday night
almost sold out. Very few tickets left.
Tony Hinchcliffe, Ian
Edwards and me. All right,
we'll see you guys next week.
Much love and joy you weekend.
And that was a blast.
Mm.